this is viral clip Alex Jones and the
Joe Rogan podcast and I think it was a
Eddie Bravo that's the comedian's name
right yeah and uh he says to Alex do you
really think that they're taking aborted
babies like you know late term to
experiment on and Alex is screaming and
ranting yes they had a vote on it's
happening and then all these articles
come out saying Alex Jones is a crackpot
conspiracy theorist and now we have
leaked documents and Yahoo news is
publishing this Yahoo news come on you
want to come out and tell me the media
is biased sure they've republished the
story they're carrying it and uh
University of Pittsburgh was doing
experiments on fetal tissue from aborted
babies some at 42 weeks old for those
that don't know what that means in the
UK at least 37 weeks is considered full
term that's like a a baby that could be
born you could do a C-section the baby's
alive
in the U.S 40 weeks is widely considered
to be a living baby so they had aborted
babies at 42 weeks and we're doing
experiments I I got to tell you man I
read this I couldn't believe it I
absolutely could not believe it they
were taking tissues I hope you're ready
for this because this is not for the
faint of Hearts not for your kids no
this is dark stuff I mean YouTube might
even take us down because it's how
sickening the stuff is but this is news
and it's being covered by a ton of
outlets and uh so I hope you're ready
for this they would take the tissue from
these babies and graft it to rats yep
very very dark stuff so we'll talk about
that
um it's not going to be a completely
dark episode you know show we we do have
a bunch to make fun of Biden about so it
will laugh and and we'll cry so I hope
you're ready for one of the more serious
shows because I I you know I saw this
story and I was like we got it how could
this be real yeah how could how could
the universities be doing this and it's
you know when when uh you know Sheamus
mentioned before the show We're a nation
of tolerators when people are just like
hey man I'm gonna mind my own business
it's like dude it's what's that saying
you know all that is needed for evil to
Triumph is for good men to do nothing
that's right well let's talk about it we
are hanging out with uh we got a good
crew it's Friday night we're gonna have
a chill night we got to Cassandra
Fairbanks hanging out hey you have uh do
you want to make an announcement oh
[Laughter]
hey everybody thanks for coming
Cassandra what's up what's the pita
thing well let's do it after the intro
[Music]
I think we should talk about that after
we have a discussion on what's been done
to these innocent children who were
killed and used for scientific
experiments I'm Sheamus of Freedom Tunes
it was funny when we started the show or
when we were going to start the show we
were doing the pre-show I kind of had
like a bit planned and some things we
were going to joke about
um to call back to last episode and some
jokes we were telling then but this is
just so dark that it kind of brought the
energy down but I think that's important
I mean there are some topics that I
think the audience should really hear
about even if it's not going to be
extremely entertaining and the reality
is we are a society of tolerators we
don't build things and we don't prevent
people from destroying things we just
let other people act in our Stead
my grandfather fought in the second
world war and after two years of
battling through Europe he liberated the
flossenburg concentration camp and he
was fluent in German
so he went to the local priest and he
asked him how could you let this happen
people were being slaughtered near your
town you knew it was going on you didn't
do anything and what the priest said was
that the SS told him if he said anything
or tried to do anything they would
comment and murder all of his
parishioners
and I remember as a kid thinking about
that and wondering what would I do in
that situation if people I knew and
loved would be killed if I spoke out
against evil but here I am and it's 2021
and we all have the opportunity to speak
out about unborn children being
slaughtered every single day about human
experiments being performed on
completely faultless defenseless human
beings who were killed in the womb about
children who were killed after they were
born so their organs could be harvested
and we don't say anything
and it has to stop it has to stop how
will we be judged we're going to get in
all that we got Lydia press on the
buttons I am pressing the buttons you
guys all know that I am super pro-life
that is my hill to die and I'm the one
that sent Sheamus's article that started
all this nonsense because it's really
bad and I'm really hoping to open
everybody's eyes a little bit to this so
hopefully it's not too dark hopefully
we're able to kind of shed some light on
it hopefully it'll be a pretty good
night we'll see you know we had a bunch
of jokes like Ron DeSantis was making
fun of Joe Biden saying his brain all
isn't all there and we're all laughing
and have a good time and then we pull up
the store and we're like
hmm
man this is the world
dude things have been getting dark I'll
tell you this we got a lot going on I
mean the military coming out in Sydney
to lock things down you've got the the
oh there's too much the Apple spying
thing they always try to go they you
know what I I want to say that because I
want to keep that in the context of what
they're doing to children so uh go to
timcast.com become a member help support
our work our Fierce and independent
journalism and like this uh video share
the show with your friends I don't know
man I would say of all of the shows to
share this is the probably the most
important but I don't know how many
people are going to want to be like look
at this yeah because I I I was reading
the story and now like shame is like
what happened I'm like I don't even know
if I want to read it to you but we're
going to do it side after Tim was
reading the details I had to go outside
for a minute my daughter was born at 36
weeks and she was a full person I mean
yeah well again I believe life begins I
shouldn't just say I believe this I mean
it is a fact that life begins at
conception but people clearly argue you
over whether an unborn child is a human
I think it's a ridiculous argument but
surely we're not arguing over whether a
child that has already been born is
human at this point but evidently we are
and you mentioned that let's let for you
mentioned 42 weeks I got to do slavery
at 40. I want to say something about
this let's pull this story up right now
yeah let's go and uh Alex Jones is right
let me let me let me first give you some
context we have from Yahoo news
government-funded scientists sought out
aborted minority babies for research I
mean on top of that it's racist what
like I'm not even trying to make a joke
about this this is insane
researchers at the University of
Pittsburgh received at least 2.7 million
dollars in federal funds to study fetal
organs and attempted to retrieve half
their samples from the aborted babies of
minorities according to documents
released Tuesday again Yahoo news
the National Institutes of Health had
overseen experiments on fetal tissue at
the University of Pittsburgh since 2015
from aboard fetuses ranging from 6 to 42
weeks or two weeks passed what is widely
considered to be full term for the
particular study in question the grant
request specified that half the samples
must come from aboard fetuses of
minorities including at least 25 percent
from African-American women according to
documents obtained by the Center for
Medical progress and Judicial Watch Let
me just stress they say they were
studying fetal organs they retrieved
them from some babies up to 42 weeks and
they had the nerve
Alex Jones Joe Rogan War leads to
conspiracy theory meltdown infowar's
house says babies harvested for organs
now maybe that's a very extreme
interpretation of it what they're saying
is admittedly not much better that the
babies had already been aborted so you
know by all means they can experiment on
that stuff but I'll tell you this man
I'll say I want to say two things first
when the law allows a baby at 42 weeks
to be aborted then someone can go well
better not let the living baby go to
waste I'll tell you this if a baby is at
42 weeks and I'm gonna operate on the
assumption
you know I'm not going to give them the
benefit of the doubt that maybe the baby
was stillborn or something like that
it's it's an aborted fetus at 42 weeks
they could have performed a C-section
and that baby is alive so this is beyond
the pale this is something I want to
know what women were carrying babies for
42 weeks to get an abortion to give it
to science to use as a human guinea pig
like what kind of person carries a baby
for 42 weeks could it could it have been
stillborn maybe like what the article
says I know I don't want to believe that
our country that universities that
they're funding this stuff I wanna I
wanna be like maybe it was
believe it man I don't believe it
stillborn is a type of abortion
involuntary abortions yeah I mean
miscarriages are called spontaneous
abortion sometimes but what we're what
we are talking about is children who
were being killed intentionally and then
experimenting we know that 100 yeah well
we know this because
um there was an expose done of Planned
Parenthood back in 2015 where they went
in with hidden cameras and found that
higher-ups at Planned Parenthood were
negotiating prices for the sale of fetal
tissue and in the footage they were
saying things like oh you know whoever
throws a price out negotiations first
loses in making jokes about the luxury
cars they wanted to buy it was really
obvious that these people were selling
this tissue for profit and what the
media repeatedly said was this footage
is deceptively edited it's not really
happening but the organization headed by
David deliden I should mention was
putting the full unedited footage on the
internet for everyone to see which isn't
what you do when you deceptively edit
footage to try to trick the public now
Kamala Harris really went after him and
did everything she could to prosecute
him in California and then very Catholic
Joe Biden selected her to be his vice
president and as soon as he's in office
he repeals the Trump era restrictions on
federal funding for experimentation
using aborted children
because that is our very Catholic
President that is The Devout
Administration under which we live right
now now we got to be careful uh
that story Planned Parenthood was
awarded a lawsuit uh over that they they
were awarded two million dollars I know
I I I believe part of that was
he didn't have their consent to film
them I mean they were very clearly
negotiating and haggling over the price
for these unborn children that they had
killed in order to sell them and turn a
profit on it is it that it was edited to
make it look like they killed them but
in in fact they had been I mean it was
it was imported by the parents it was
planned parenthood right so what they do
is perform abortions and then they were
selling the tissue after the fact I
guess if I'll say the other s Planned
Parenthood to abort the kid who's the
Killer is it the mother or we don't we
don't need to bring the story up we have
a new story right now I guess sure sure
my point is that this is something we've
known about yeah well that the the issue
there is if we want this to be clean and
straightforward and be able to tell
people when you're sitting down for
dinner with your family members who
don't believe you and you bring up that
story they're going to say oh they lost
those people lost that lawsuit they were
Liars no we have a story right now we
don't need to bring up the past they're
doing this we have documents that were
released they are buying this stuff I
don't care where they're buying it from
yeah no I think both stories are still
important uh in part because again the
full footage is available online for
people to watch if somebody doesn't
believe you I think it's an easy
argument to make the crazy thing about
this is it like I I gotta I'm gonna I
hope your your kids aren't listening my
friends because
let me let me let me uh let me let me
read this
all right
for the particular study in question the
grant request specified that half the
samples must come from a board of
fetuses minorities as we read projects
funded by the National Institutes of
Health must ensure appropriate inclusion
of women and minorities
they should also ensure distribution of
the study that they should also ensure
distribution of the study reflects the
population needed to accomplish the
scientific goals Selden said that one of
the goals is to support researchers
looking for treatments and cures for
kidney disease which disproportionately
affects minorities Selden added that
research researchers have no part in any
decisions as to timing method or
procedures used to terminate the
pregnancy CMP founder and president
David de Laden slammed the university in
a statement on Tuesday
the NIH Grant application for just one
of Pitt's numerous experiments with
aborted fetus infants reads like an
episode American Horror Story law
enforcement and public officials should
act immediately to bring the next next
Kermit Gosnell to justice under the law
the stuff that they were doing was uh
was was absolutely insane I don't know
where we had that oh yeah so I had
another story pulled up that was talking
about the grafting of fat tissue but I
guess I can't find it I don't know did
it get removed
I had a story pulled up um about that
here I had some information about that
here that I can pull up that they were
um they were scalping five-month-old uh
please I mean again for the faint of
heart
they were scalping five-month-old
aborted fetuses to stitch onto Lab Rats
who said who is
um this is I have it I have this from
music right here okay gosh yeah it says
in one study published last year Pitt
scientists described scalping
five-month-old aborted babies to stitch
onto the back backs of Lab Rats they
wrote about how they cut the scalps from
the heads and backs of the babies
scraping off the excess fat under the
baby's skin before stitching it onto the
rats they even included photos of the
baby's hair growing out of the scalps
each Scout belonged to a little
Pennsylvania baby whose head would grow
those same hairs if he or she were not
aborted for experiments with Lab Rats
now that's propaganda it's a dead body
it's not hold on what do you mean that's
propaganda yeah
someone chose to abort that child and
now to call it a baby is disingenuous
because it's not disappointed they
killed a baby and okay then it's a baby
course and they're so a corpse and
they're sowing its scalp to a rat
will they find the value they find the
infant skin cells are are good for like
stem cells because they're so young and
vibrant I guess so they're using like
stem cell experiments they use infants
that
it's why they're doing it with those
cells particularly scientifically I just
don't I don't understand why it's
propaganda or how because they're like
if this child hadn't been then it would
have been a glowing baby
that's literally the fact how many weeks
are in five months
20. ish finding from Newsweek from 2015
finding that babies born at 22 weeks can
survive could change abortion debate
dude this 43 premature babies in five
months can survive it's a 10-month
abortion 42 weeks is when that's insane
I think I'm in the one trimester camp
and then after that I think it's murder
I think it's alive I think it has a
brain I think it's a human but in the
first you know couple three months it's
still develops listen listen it's a
person I mean from conception where else
do you draw the line like when the brain
is formed the thing I find the craziest
about this is that this story is from
May okay and I write news all day for
two websites and I didn't hear any of
these details about it but all day today
I mean everybody was outraged about
fauci killing puppies which they should
be right but why isn't there the same
outrage about literal like full-term
babies
like agree this is I mean we talk about
like that that Infamous uh group of
Japanese scientists that you know they
were recruited what was it called was
that operation paperclipse Fahrenheit No
No operation was it paper clip were they
uh paper clips where they brought all
the Nazi scientists to the U.S I believe
that's correct um the Japanese Camp
there was a camp where they were like
units
47 I want to say no seven something so I
don't remember I'm sorry yes science is
a brutal industry that's for sure I mean
right extremely unethical like the
science has to be restricted based on
legitimate ethical concerns there are
certain things you shouldn't be able to
do
the the Japanese scientists would like
take a prisoner and stick their arm out
of the door like into the cold and watch
it freeze yep and then like shatter it
while the person was still alive in the
other room to see what would happen to
him they say that um what we know about
frostbite largely comes from the
Japanese doing research on live human
beings that's horrible I mean people
talk about the Nazi um experiments like
rightly condemn them pretty much across
the board and then we're doing it here
like we're literally doing it in
Pittsburgh
well and it's crazy because people I
mean look people are comfortable with
things like this happening as long as
they never have to think about it right
they can know what's going on but if
it's not brought up then they're able to
sleep at night for whatever reason and
I know that
after
um for example you know the the uh
Second World War I mentioned this
earlier my grandfather and his unit
marched all of the townspeople through
the camp to show them this is what
happened here this is what you allowed
we have unparalleled technological
infrastructure for communication this
information should be very easy to get
to people but the people who have uh you
know access to the gatekeeping more or
less don't want the information getting
out there and so even when you do have
access to the information people will
shame you for discussing it so I know
that there are some campus organizations
and other pro-life groups that will show
people what an abortion actually looks
like show people the aftermath of an
unborn child that's been killed and
people consider that to be evil or cruel
the act of doing it isn't evil or cruel
but showing people a picture of it
that's unreasonable what matters is no
one ever has to confront what we're
doing we have to protect everybody's
feelings we have to make sure they don't
feel guilty about what Society is doing
and about what the abortionists are
doing and the fact that no one is
standing up to stop it the real crime is
showing someone that they've supported
evil not the evil itself the important
clarification for the sake of all of the
fact Checkers would be
people are getting abortions and then
doctors are buying the the theaters
right we don't want to conflate it that
the doctors are murdering the children
and taking it's like the the I don't
know
I mean but you are complicit if you know
that a child was aborted and you are
receiving the tissue let's let's let's
let's try it a different way let's say
that um
you're a researcher and you need fresh
corpses that are you know
from someone who died in the immediate
and there's a guy who somehow just keeps
happening to have them all for you to
buy yeah you see the problem I have with
this is that they they they they Lobby
for a thing to happen and then exploit
the worst aspects of it and one of the
most horrifying and disgusting ways like
I don't I don't even know man I don't
this is
making me think of like a um industrial
animal Slaughter because they'll they'll
not let people see that stuff either I
got a problem with that too yeah but
also but nobody says some blood in the
pools around and that's all bad it's all
about that they won't let people they
won't let people take pictures
they don't let you take photos of pita
ripping animals away from the
sanctuaries that they're in and they
have the courts siding with them and
issuing gag orders on people and
um not allowing any filming but and also
Ian the big differences hide their
crimes exactly I think there's another
Point here to be made because there's a
significant difference when somebody
shows me an animal being killed right
and of course there are more and less
ethical ways to kill an animal but I can
still say I believe that it's okay to
kill animals to eat them if you show me
factory farming I can say this is the
wrong way of doing it but no one says
it's cruel or inhumane or evil to show
someone who has eaten meat what happens
when you kill an animal in order to get
that meat but it's considered cruel and
inhumane to show to people who are
considering abortion what abortion
actually looks like no I think people
get mad at you if you show them the
factory farming I think there are some
people who will get mad at you but
generally speaking people understand
that they're being provided with more
information I think most people
including people who eat meat
understand that factory farming is
really messed up it's really messed up
man I've been to the Farms where they
have like the organic meat and I was so
impressed I've told the story before
where the cows are just like the door is
open there's no gate and I'm like what
is this it's like are the cows are going
to leave and the farmers like where are
they going to go and I'm like anywhere
and he's like like they got food here
and I was like Wow and so the the cows
are happy they live full lives they have
food it's all automatic and the farmer
just lets them do their thing and then
I've also driven past the factory farms
where the ground is sludge and they're
all packed in and it's horrifying and it
smells I saw undercover video at a
factory farm of one of the guys and what
happens is people either they find
people that are already psychotic no
offense if you work at a factory farm or
people that are just willing to allow
themselves to be okay with murdering and
what they'll do is they train themselves
to see pig that means it has to die and
they'll they treat it like like a piece
of wood like they'll pick up a baby and
Smash It On The Ground until it explodes
its head and then they'll like throw it
in a pile and there's like living
animals screaming as they're getting hit
they started passing these laws
you couldn't film the horrible things
they do like dude I'm all about we're
raising chickens I don't know if we'll
eat these ones because they're the stars
of chicken City so they might they might
get you know a pardon but uh we're
raising a couple babies and I got no
problem eating the animals and growing
the vegetables and we try you try and do
it right you know we're we're we
understand now uh some people don't eat
meat because they don't want to cause
suffering they don't want uh you know
for me I'm like well you know I'll hunt
and I'll eat but we're gonna do it right
we're gonna minimize suffering of the
animal and we're gonna accept that this
is part of the life cycle but man I've
seen some of these videos where like a
guy I watched a guy like punt a chicken
just for no reason no reason and I'm
like dude it's because it's it's it's
mechanized it's just shuffling they
throw them in the grinder and it's just
it's horrible man it's really horrible
stuff to watch you know and uh
I don't know what you do in that regard
people are definitely willing to
tolerate that but I'll tell you when it
comes to what they're willing to do to
human beings exactly it's like why would
I be surprised that they horribly
mistreat the animals who are already
living horrible lives when you can see
what people are willing to do to each
other exactly when you look at what
people do to other human beings and it's
no surprise that we have this
unbelievably horrific Warfare state
where people are killed in other
countries in the United States
government will either do it or support
governments that will go to war and
commit violence against civilians like
the Saudi Arabian government has been
doing in Yemen because if I don't have
an obligation to care for my own unborn
child and it's okay for me to kill them
then why should I care about somebody on
the other side of the world we need that
we will not have world peace for as long
as we have abortion we will not
we got uh
I don't know I don't I don't know what
the root of this issue is I know I can
already hear many of the leftists saying
it's capitalism it's the you know they
cut costs they reduce costs and I'm like
I don't think that's it people people
want and will eat meat and you end up
with these really nasty situations and
not to mention what goes on with factory
farming results in infected meat and
then they put like where they put like
ammonium or something yeah in the beef
because of the bacteria preserves it
yeah I tell you this you guys with
antibiotics I have been saying get out
of the cities for some time for a
variety of reasons yeah I've been
talking about you know growing your own
food and raising our chickens for a
while now where we live we can drive
15-20 minutes and be at a farm and
there's one Farm nearby it's like
self-checkout it's the craziest thing I
heard you you walk in there's nobody
there and they've got like freezers with
the meat freshly harvested from like
organic field farm-raised animals and
you walk up you grab it you scan it you
pay you walk out nobody's even there I'm
like that's amazing that's amazing you
can see the animals we went to one farm
and all the goats ran out and they were
all yelling at us and we were laughing
and the goats have this nice little and
they're jumping up and down and they're
dancing having a good time and I'm like
they're living it yeah you know we Farm
it's what we do but they're having a
good time while they're here no I agree
I agree it's like um the luxury of like
European agricultural life being out
here but with the value of the United
States like uh product lines like you
can order anything and receive anything
by delivery but we live like in this
awesome
Farm man there's a lot of people in this
country that don't care about anything
and that's what really bothers me you
know because we we pulled up the polling
data the other day from Civics and saw
that among Democrat voters they think
the economy is doing fairly good and
among Independents and conservatives
they say it's fairly bad why because
those are the people that are in reality
and so I genuinely think like you know
you look at people who live in rural
areas who tend to be conservative like
they raise animals they take care of
their animals they're not living in
cities where it's mechanized pollution
and waste and factory farming to get
enough food into those cities is very
very very difficult I mean cities can be
great for a lot of reasons I know some
people are like hey stop bragging on
cities and I get it arts and culture can
be fun but the the difficulty in
bringing in resources into cities it's
crazy when you go to New York and you
see how you can't park anywhere there's
delivery trucks on every road all the
time because they got to get enough food
in for the massively tall skyscrapers it
is not an easy thing to do so they
mechanize the process they mechanize
factory farms they Mass produce as much
as they can I tell you this dude when
Alex Jones was here is another thing he
was right about and he told me did you
know you're eating cloned beef and I
said no we're not we're not eating
cloned beef that's crazy and then I
Googled it yeah we've been eating cloned
beef they clone the animals that is
mind-blowing how awful all this stuff is
I am a lifelong vegetarian yeah you're
happy about it yeah you've never eaten
me no I mean look I got no problem
eating me I mean before three I think I
did I saw Bambi and it screwed me all up
my parents indulged me thinking it was
the phase and my stubbornness I just
never ate it again
as like uh are you vegan
um not currently I went through you know
a big like eight year chunks of being
vegan with you've been vocally
supportive animal rights do you find
that there's a through line with the
abortion and animal agriculture
um I mean I think that it's all terrible
things that we're closing our eyes to I
I think that factory farming is terrible
but I also I hate the animal rights
industry also anybody who's been
following me knows this very well
um my I think my current
and I've dedicated my life to now
destroying Peta in any way possible I'm
going to be meeting with Senators next
month and I am working on a massive
project including probably a documentary
about the evil stuff that they're doing
but people turn a blind eye to it
because like a lot of things
um you know you have like antifa who
claim that they're anti-fascist that
sounds so nice and lovely and we all
hate fashion it's terrible yeah
um Peta people for the ethical treatment
of animals actually kill more animals
than a lot of these things that they're
fighting I mean they got three chimps
killed last year they just seized six
chimps from a very lovely Sanctuary that
I went and saw in person myself
um so I think that people are just
you know they like to think that they're
doing good people will donate to Peta
without looking into the fact that
they've killed 75 of all animals that
come into their Virginia animal shelter
and people will be like oh we're
pro-choice because women have a right to
their body and that's great and
wonderful but they don't think about the
cost of any of those things they don't
think about what's really happening what
these organizations are really doing
and I think that it all kind of ties in
together in a way that we all just like
to look away from terrible things being
done this is the non-profit industry you
know I I worked for these fundraising
organizations and the reason they work
is because you're going to people and
this is what I would actually tell
people you are selling hopes and dreams
you are selling absolvement of
responsibility because when we would go
out we would fundraise for the
environment or for specific groups any
specific like advocacy we'd be like hey
you're busy we get it you can't actively
do these things so let us do it why
don't you pitch in it worked for them
too that's right and so people would be
like make sense to me here's money and
then when I find out what they do with
that money I got really mad I ended up
jumping organizations like oh these
people are bad and then I realized hey
wait a minute that group was bad too and
then I realized wow they're like most of
them are bad yeah have you ever seen
poverty Ink No I would just recommend
everybody check that out it's sort of an
expose on the organizations
internationally that claim that they're
lifting people out of poverty and
through you know foreign aid and
charitable Works improving circumstances
in underdeveloped countries but uh
they're more or less in it for
themselves They Don't Really achieve the
results that they claim they're going to
it's a very good documentary it's been a
while since I've seen it so I wouldn't
be able to do it justice in my summary
but I would recommend everybody check it
out I was watching uh Rogan a little I
watched Rogan pretty much frequently and
they he had a guest on they were talking
about the homeless industry in
California and they get I don't know if
it's billion is it over a billion
dollars a year but what happens is it
goes to the executives of these
companies that are supposedly taken care
of and they make six digits 250 000
salary 300 000 salary 400 000 so it's so
profitable for those people that they
don't want to fix the problem as long as
they're working on the problem they're
making bang this is why Thomas Saul says
never put activists in charge of solving
the problem they make their money off of
a problem being there well Ingrid
Newkirk actually sorry to keep going
back to Peta I'm completely obsessed
with taking them down uh Ingrid Newkirk
the president of PETA she they brag all
the time oh she only takes a 30 000 a
year salary she look at this great human
she really cares about animals even
though she's completely lobbying for all
pitbulls to be eradicated there to be no
pets in human homes including cats and
dogs and that she is personally killed
thousands of dogs with her own hands
um but she is worth millions of dollars
despite taking only this thirty thousand
dollar a year salary I can explain how
this works
um I can't speak for PETA specifically I
can't speak for other organizations and
I can explain to you
501c3 you guys want a 501c3s non-profit
organization it's uh tax deductible
non-political and these are the
organizations you have to often hear
about where they say you know your your
donation to us is tax deductible in
certain circumstances they will and then
they'll say our executive director only
takes 40 000 a year because they are
good and Noble what they don't tell you
is that they operate a 501c4 another
kind of non-profit uh 51c4 is also I
believe they they that's that's the
designation for super Pacs as well they
don't need to disclose their donations
it's not tax deductible and that's where
they pay the big bucks so what will
happen is you'll have two nonprofits a
501c3 and a 501c4 the 501c3 does all the
press and announces our executive
director gets paid nothing and what they
don't tell because they don't have to is
that the director also gets paid another
couple hundred thousand dollars out of
the pocket of the 501c4 and when you
make a donation often you don't read the
fine print and you don't realize you're
actually donating to the 501c4
and then what happens is some of these
organizations will take all the money in
the 501c4 and they'll tell you like oh
you know what because we do political
work we're not tax deductible and then
what happens is when they make 100
million dollars into their 501c4 they
give only but 5 million to the 501c3
then they come back to you and say
last year we only brought in five
million dollars and our executive
director only makes thirty thousand
years I did not know that that's
incredible that's money laundering it's
legal it's legal there there are
non-profits they're brilliant what they
do they'll organize like 10 different
non-profits and there'll be like nine
people and they'll rotate the board of
directors of each non-profit and they
all circulate funding it's amazing this
industry what they're doing is pretty
impressive too they're they're going
around right now and they're just trying
to set precedence for future cases so
they're going to roadside zoos they're
going to small farms they're going to
all these different places where people
have exotic animals and whether they're
cared for well or not they're going in
there they're suing them they're filing
Esa lawsuits against them claiming that
they have standing to seize these
animals the judges are siding with them
but they're doing it to people who don't
have the money to fight back because
these organizations are huge and they're
spending millions of dollars and so
they're setting all these residents now
so they can go after the bigger people
later actually John Pierce who you guys
have had on from the nclu he has a whole
bunch of client he took on my friend
Tanya who had her chips taken from her
by Peta last month and now all these
people who have been victims of Peter
coming out of the woodwork and he's
investigating their cases and it looks
like people are going to start fighting
back finally because they're teaming up
together and I am very excited for it
because I I am like Furious about them I
want to I want to ask you guys a
question but first I I'll tell you a
little story I was reading this in like
I can't remember what it was it was an
old timey like law precedence book was
probably like one of those magazines you
read in the bathroom or something and it
said that there was an old case where
like two farmers had land that butted up
against each other and uh one one you
know farmer a his dog kept going on to
the farmer bees land and farmer B kept
getting mad saying get your dog off my
property and the guy was like I'm sorry
you know get over here you know Fido and
then one day farmer B took out his gun
and shot the dog and killed him
and then farmer a was like you killed my
dog how dare you and the court said you
know property loss your dog shouldn't
have gone on to his property so he owes
you the damages for the Lost Property
and I remember reading that being like
my dog is not property my dog is a
friend and if you do anything to my
friends John which brings me to the
question
if someone came to your home
and took your dog and then killed it for
no reason what would you do
I can't say what I would do or the fudge
will knock on my door and hold on is
this are we talking about John Wick here
yeah is that well let's just say they
made a movie about it which ended up
becoming what are they they're going on
movie four now yeah because the Dude
wanted to be left alone and some dudes
killed his dog and John Wick what an
awesome movie I got a story here it's
from a few years ago from the guardian
Peta says sorry for taking girls pet
Chihuahua and putting it down Animal
Rights group pays family 49 000 to set a
lawsuit after it sees the dog named Maya
which belonged to a nine-year-old they
say Wilbur zarati from Virginia had sued
the group for taking his daughter's
Chihuahua from a mobile home park on the
state's Eastern Shore and euthanizing it
before the end of the required five-day
grace period zarati alleged Peta operate
under a broad policy of euthanizing
animals including healthy ones because
it considers pet ownership to be a form
of involuntary bondage that's right so
you just kill the the animal that makes
sense wow Peter denied the allegation
and maintained the incident was a
terrible mistake I'm sorry I've seen a
ton of videos on Reddit there was one
surveillance footage where you see
someone run onto the porch and grab an
animal have you seen that one yeah
that's crazy have you seen the foot the
photos of PETA like there they used to
dump the carcasses of dogs into Walmart
dumpsters and stuff Huffington Post
actually did an incredible expose I hate
praising The Huffington Post but it was
incredible
um because they were just killing all
these dogs and they had nowhere to put
them so they were throwing them in
dumpsters and the state inspector for
Virginia actually did a report being
like how are you taking in this many
dogs when you don't have any place to
put them how is this a shelter and they
wanted to shut it down but Peta used
their big lobbying money to to keep
running and they killed more dogs last
year than they did the year before that
how many uh you're probably not the
answer but Ian Sheamus feel free to
chime in and for those listening at home
feel free to throw in your super chats
with your guesses in today's trivia
question how many dogs does PETA kill
every year
twenty thousand you know what's funny I
have no idea what it is but I was also
going to guess twenty thousand well that
is a full uh that is that is ten times
too many it's two thousand dogs they
don't sound that bad now Tim so that
that actually is only the numbers for
their Virginia shelter where they kill
animals
um they used a whole bunch of their
donations instead of throwing adoption
events they used them to buy giant
freezers for carcasses hope you all Pita
donors know that but um they actually
traveled to Mexico as well and they go
down there and euthanize all the street
dogs and those numbers are not counted
really they also take they seize animals
from all these little roadside zoos and
sanctuaries those numbers are not
counted there's currently a lion missing
They seized a lion from a a rescue
there's a lionfish so let me tell you
guys the story gosh uh so there's a
sanctuary rescue in Maryland the guy
takes like exotic pets that have been
thrown away that people can't can't
afford is this Tiger King uh no
better but he
um actually the nclu is going to be
representing some people from Tiger King
and that's a whole interesting other
story that I'll get into one day but um
there's this place and he takes like
exotic throwaway pets think people you
know people go get a tiger or a monkey
and then they can't care for it this guy
takes them
so he had two tigers and a lion and Peta
filed a lawsuit against them saying he
was violating the esa because the lion
liked him too much they said that it was
too bonded to the caretaker and
therefore it was unnatural and the court
sided with them sent the lion and the
two tigers to a shelter I mean a
sanctuary in Colorado and now he went to
go visit him in I believe February of
last year I could be wrong and he said
that they looked terrible like they were
in great shape when he had him now they
look terrible and now nobody has seen
him since and so I actually called The
Sanctuary asking if I could get proof of
life and because nobody has seen them
and this place is open to the public
they let people take Public tours which
makes means it's basically the same
thing he was doing but um they wouldn't
they told me there's no recent photos
but that they're supposedly alive
um and so now he's he's trying to get
proof of life and nobody will give it to
so I mean Peta the things that I've
learned in the last couple weeks have
been keeping me up at night about what
this organization oh I'm sure yeah and I
I'm I'm definitely here for the pita
bashing but also at the same time but
also at the same time I think when we're
treating human beings the way that we
treat them I just don't think there's
any Hope for Animals you best to be
believing in Nightmare dystopia is
Sheamus because you're living in one
science fiction dystopia stories written
one is it that Peta is looking for
animals that they think are in like
rough situations and then they take them
and but then they can't support them so
they execute them well what they claim
so they don't believe that there should
be any animals in human care there was a
lawsuit that they they were involved in
where they said that no elephants should
be transported to this Zoo they said the
elephants would be better dead than in
zoos and being fed by humans those were
the whole better dead than fed thing
came from but um they don't believe
anybody should have pets they don't
believe you should have a cat they don't
even think you should have a goldfish
and so what they're doing is they're
going around trying to shut down all
these like smaller sanctuaries who don't
agree to play by their rules don't agree
to work with them and they're taking
them and they're sending them to these
these other sanctuaries through our
courts it's essentially civil asset
forfeiture but through a private
organization
um and it's a loophole in the esa which
shouldn't exist exotic
um Endangered Species Act
and they're they're sending them off to
these places but they're not considering
the welfare of the animals for example
with Tonya haddix's case they just went
and seized chimps from her in St Louis
or near St Louis
um these chimps were were bonded they
were a troop they were in a huge
enclosure it was bigger than my house
there was several stories tall it was
beautiful
um but they claim that they know better
and so last year they took three chimps
from a sanctuary put in a different
Sanctuary called project chimps and
project chimps got them killed because
they put them in with random chimps that
they didn't know these chimps were older
they were retired from research and from
entertainment they didn't have the alpha
ability to defend themselves so they got
killed and then 22 whistleblowers came
out against project chimp and alleged
abuse mistreatment filthy eat conditions
all kinds of stuff and Peta didn't
disavow them the way that they do for
all these little things sanctuaries that
are operating all over the country
instead they put out a statement being
like this is terrible and continued
working with them so when they come in
and they seize these animals they're
putting them in great danger and it's
yeah
and I can I want to highlight a specific
person though her name is Mary Beth
Sweetland oh you know who that is
she is uh well apparently according to
at least one website called actually let
me just show it this is humanewatch.org
Mary Beth Sweetland is best known as the
Peta executive who vigorously campaigned
against medical research with animals
even though she is a diabetic whose
Health relies on injecting herself with
insulin that has been tested on animals
now over at Peta they do she does say
that she's on what is this called uh
Humulin a synthetically produced insulin
is much more appropriate for the human
body okay I can respect that that's from
2010 they say but I will also mention
that News Guard rates Peta as caution
the website fails to adhere to several
basic journalistic standards I I know
that this is they call it fake news yeah
they are fake news today I was fighting
with the VP of PETA on Twitter because
that idiot made her way into my mentions
and she put up to take a dig at me
because I've been defending Tanya so
hard she put up a press release about
what the chimps and Festus and it was a
photo of one of the cages indoors that
they use for like when they need to
tranquilize them or when they need to go
into clean the cage it's like a
temporary enclosure and they didn't show
any of the rest of the property they
blamed her for things that happened 70
years ago when she's only been in charge
of the chimp since 2017.
um they put up this like wild I mean it
was impressive how fake news it was I
was like holy crap like if I read this I
would be outraged I would be really
fascinated to know how these animal
rights activists who are against
experimenting on animals for the benefit
of humanity feel about the kind of
research we were discussing earlier with
unborn children oh you know Peta
wouldn't care yeah I really doubt they'd
care at all no of course not they might
care about the rats
so right that is horrible you're so
right wow that's like the worst yeah
that's horrible humans are animals I
mean we're ethical treatment of animals
humans are animals yes
I think they're smart animals so
scientifically we're the smartest animal
but here's here's a question for
everyone here do you believe there's a
fundamental difference between humans
and animals yes no humans are absolutely
I think absolutely yeah but I I also
deeply care about animals for sure for
sure you can still care about animals
but agree that like humans are superior
once what saw a very important uh film I
talked greatly about this it was called
All Dogs Go to Heaven yes theologically
inaccurate no no great movie though they
do go to heaven I won't hear other ones
of course they do what's the loophole do
you know what that loophole in the esa
is that's letting Peta go in and um so
they're letting them claim standing
because you can't just go in and be like
I oppose War so I'm gonna I'm gonna Sue
Lockheed Martin and take all the bombs
and decide what do with them which was
my fiance's great analogy here
um but you can't that will be based you
can't extremely based but with the esa
you can because they the judges are
claiming The Endangered Species Act so
the judges are claiming that because
Peta cares about animals they have
standing in these cases what if we had
like an endangered humans act that could
allow you to uh sue people from bombing
people in parts of the world where
they're killing civilians routine or
like bombing civilians the farms and
fishing boats or aiding governments that
are bombing Farms the issue as humans
are far from endangered that's all
actually I did that yeah but I did that
back humans are actually in a really
dangerous course
yeah yeah so we may have there may be
lots of people but boy I'll tell you
this if we saw like a bunch of chimps
and one had an RPG we'd be like they're
in danger you know what I mean like we
got nukes man yeah yeah
there Peta is like taking people's homes
and stuff now though and it's gotten to
the point where it's insane
um there's this guy Tim Stark a lot of
you probably know him from Tiger King I
was talking to him the other day they're
taking his home because they they not
only went and took all his animals but
then they sued for legal fees which she
has to recoup which came I believe he
was they were awarded 750 000 so not
only are they getting these animals
they're getting almost a million dollars
and
um it's it's just crazy to me that like
this is even allowed but I was talking
to him and he made a great point that
Under The Endangered Species Act it
counts they count Tigers because in the
wild they're endangered and so the
Endangered Species Act is supposed to
apply to wild animals if you count all
the tigers that are in captivity in the
United States
um because they're being the esa is
being applied to them they're not
considered endangered anymore because
there's like 10 000 tigers in the
Captivity or something
and so they're just using all these
weird bizarre loopholes to to create
precedent for future cases so they can
go after more people bigger people
it's time for for people of Good Will to
uh stand up man huh we need people to
become more more um organized and more
active
I guess the issue is that there's too
many
maybe maybe the fault lies with the
average working American who is I
wouldn't say comfortable in a sense I
mean you're always striving and
struggling in some respect but pulled
out of the fight in general I don't
think average Americans need to be
involved in a battle against Pete or
anything like that I just mean like all
of this well sure sure I I just I see
all this bad stuff that's happening
whether it be the stuff we normally rag
about with you know uh with with
critical race applied principles and now
with you know what's going on with these
experiments and I'm like man if people
were just all calm reasonable mature but
active and and voice their opinions this
stuff would never happen you can't voice
your opinions half the things that
people want to say about like the way
that you would want to respond to people
grafting dead baby Parts onto a rat
would get you banned on any social exact
platform even talking about that
happening not only and it's not even
just about social media platforms if you
bring that up in front of people they're
gonna look at you like you're crazy
imagine if everyone did yeah they should
dude the fact that they're not as an
Outreach the fact that that happened and
also the fact that the story broke a
while ago basically no one talked about
it at the time but no one really knows
about it anymore now is insane didn't
the U.S order like photos to be taken as
much as possible after World War II so
yes yes I remember that there you go yep
and it was a good thing now people know
exactly what was going on and what we
vowed never let happen again so when
when you see any of these stories as
horrible as they are how do we how do we
tolerate any of this it's it made me
think of North Korea yeah right or
struggling so like in North Korea
everyone's starving so they don't have
time to think about anything other than
where's my food I need to get food on
purpose we're not starving and all we
think think about is food and we're
going to get our next meal and how we
can sit on the couch and entertain
ourselves in front of the television or
with our smartphone I mean it's
unbelievable you know Joseph Stalin and
Mao Zedong and all these horrific
dictators historically did everything
they could to pull people away from God
with violence it turns out all you
really needed to do was develop your
economy enough for nice gadgets to be
put in everyone's hands and they would
just forget about him and then they
would let anyone treat anyone else any
kind of way and when no one would stand
up for the truth because no one would
have developed enough virtue to do
anything that was even remotely
difficult or compromised their social
standard remember uh wall mounted phones
yes yeah I was watching a video on
Reddit and it was like high def 1993 in
New York and I was like oh you you poor
fools you have no no idea what lies
ahead I think the internet for all of
its wonders there's a lot of negatives
to it because for you know for every
action there's an equal and opposite the
internet's an amazing stuff here we are
you know talking to you but it's like
you said Sheamus it's also it's it's man
it's it's plugged people into this
machine where they've gone nuts when
here's what scares me
when a regular person of strong mental
fortitude sees dumb stuff on the
internet they are Discerning and they
can reject or say that I don't you know
I don't trust this we're all research or
I'll look into it more but when stupid
people see it they just plug right in
and say you got it and they follow along
with whatever nightmarish Trend happens
and that's the crazy thing you know I
see a lot of people tweeting like I
wonder how it went how how did people
let it get to that point and you know
throughout history I'm not talking about
World War II because it's over over
um it's it's cited so often it's you
know Godwin's law but you think about
any dictatorial Uprising how did people
let it happen we had a guy in here who
was fighting against Castro when he was
a young man he was Castro took over and
it was like it was a revolution and
everyone was cheering for but then
slowly and slowly and slowly Castro kept
doing more and more script things until
he controlled everything and it's like
how did people let that happen because
one small thing at a time I'm not gonna
stand up and I'm not going to say
anything that might upset the people
around me over this small issue and then
it just piles on and piles on and piles
on them before you you know it it's far
too late to do anything
Ian people and your leaders is so
dangerous having faith in other people
Blind Faith yeah it's not that obviously
I want to have faith in you you guys
like we're talking I believe in you as a
human I have faith that you're going to
do what you say you're going to do but
there's like a level up there's like a a
diminishing return to that like you
gotta
believing that they're gonna do what
they tell you whoever they are whether
it's you or you like there's it's
dangerous that's dangerous and if you if
you authorize some sort of massive
political power and you just believe
they're gonna do what they say I don't
like it well I don't think it's so much
blind trust in leadership as much as it
is not voicing your opposition when you
clearly don't trust them I think a lot
of people don't trust people in power
and I think that they know that there
are very screwed up things happening in
the world such as the things we were
discussing earlier with human
experiments being done on innocent
faultless children
but they just don't say anything because
it's uncomfortable because it's
unpopular
you're right and I think we can also uh
lighten the mood a little bit by giving
a good example of bad leadership and
what happens when you have a population
that just blindly marches behind blind
leadership and refuses to accept it we
have a series of stories actually the
first of which is that Ron DeSantis said
to Joe Biden I don't want to hear a blip
out of you until you secure the Border
because he accused Joe Biden of
importing the virus what is it like 7
000 uh seven thousand in Macau in Texas
tested positive I believe and Joe Biden
this is the craziest thing Biden's like
we're going to require All Foreign
visitors to be vaccinated but illegal
immigrants it's optional no I'm not
kidding literally they're like we'll
offer it to you if you want it but 1.2
million people so so Joe Biden responds
saying governor who
and Ron DeSantis had the best comeback
because I don't think God who I am I
don't think that's what I would hit him
he said what else has he forgotten oh my
God
I remember Obama making fun of trump
this way just this dismissive like yeah
who does he that guy's nobody he will
never he's like uh fortunately I will be
remembered as a president you remember
that you're missing the uh uh I'll be
remembered
be remembered uh
yeah yeah just and now there's a really
funny article it was like it was from
the Independent Rhonda Santos's
popularity plummets after Joe Biden says
governor who and I'm like no it didn't
work
well no no it's a spurious correlation
it's like his his approval rating goes
down because of covet in Florida or
something and then Biden says governor
who and they they saw that spurious
correlation do you think anyone who
likes Ron DeSantis was like Joe Biden
just eviscerated
this is just like when Trump told
Hillary she'd be in shouts right I just
can't believe that Biden like especially
when this is someone who actually
probably did forget who he was Biden
wasn't even trying to slam him
but samples uh guy they got Harry Larry
Birds corn pop corn pop check it out
check us out check us out from
timcast.com Biden says 350 million
Americans have been vaccinated more than
U.S population what I what I love the
most I thought we were up to 370. I
thought we went to 333 you know what I
you know what I really love about
timcast.com is uh uh you know we're
we're doing our best not always wrong
but this title is perfect we don't snark
we're not making fun of them we're
literally just stating the fact Biden
says 350 million Americans have been
vaccinated comma more than U.S
population yeah we don't need to explain
anything else the news it's right there
it speaks for itself
our our uh non-partisan factual band I
was gonna say our president ain't there
dude no he's really not well at least
we're laughing huh yeah
yeah your story
humor well but what do we do when you
it's also like a genuinely evil human
being
horrible not evil just you guys should
read Biden Inc from Politico where
they're like conveniently when Joe Biden
was put in charge of Iraq his brother
got all the contracts for building
things there hold on that's an
unverified conspiracy theory from
politico.com unverified conspiracy
website oh yeah I love I love it yeah
they are I mean Politico reported that
uh ukrainians were scrambling after they
had tried to help Hillary Clinton in the
election and you know interfering and a
Court ruled as such and then later
Politico reported never happened there
was no interference and I'm like
political retract your story but they
would they had both simultaneously
running it was it was it was beautiful
it was a beautiful Paradox of fake news
yeah Politico was funny earlier I was
reading an article on the Biden
Administration repealing the Trump era
rules against Federal funding going
towards research done on unborn children
who were killed in abortion and the
article described the Trump regulations
as very strict and these very strict
Trump era regular relations are being
unwinded by Joe Biden like okay he
should just let him kill a little bit
yeah
we're never gonna do
anything
that's like a thumb at least is it that
people the theory the idea is that
people are gonna get abortions so you
may as well use that's what we're saying
basically
look at all the the fetal tissue that
one's at 42 weeks I mean it's a living
baby but remember remember that South
Park episode where uh Christopher Reeves
oh man was yeah I don't remember that
one so so uh in the episode Christopher
Reeves again is a wheelchair and then he
takes a baby and he cracks it open and
then he sucks it dry and then he stands
up from his wheelchair the South Park
guys are are brilliantly funny the issue
was though they were mocking the idea as
if it didn't happen as if these look
obviously Christopher Reeves never did
that there's nobody who's literally
taking the babies and cracking them open
but it's it's it's an analogy I suppose
I guess they were exaggerating for
humorous sake but we see these stories
since 2015. well and also I mean there
you can do stem cell research without
killing unborn children there are I mean
the umbilical cord is rich in stem cells
there are also stem cells that they've
been able to extract from adults and
they tend to be more effective in
experiments than the ones that are
coming from children they're killing I'm
gonna tell you man when once we get into
the AI era all sense of human decency is
gone you think you were past that point
man no no no no
we're decent to humans who are
interfacing with right but as soon as
someone's out of our space we don't care
we're complete sociopaths a robot is
going to treat a human like we would a
lab rat also when the AI when the AI
comes in and you get like an Ultron or
whatever look at what they do we talked
a lot about China right how they just
will bulldoze homes because like you
don't own it anyway it's a lease there's
no eminent domain there they just do
whatever they want so we had Jack
basobic telling us how like you know the
the Democrats or the you know the US
politicians go over there and they're
like you can just basically Crush an
entire residential neighborhood and
build a highway and they're like yep
we're not even at that level in the
United States necessarily we have like
oh well there's a lawsuit in the
Constitution an eminent domain the Fifth
Amendment you've got to pay you know et
cetera yeah once you get to the AI air
level they're going to be like the
robot's gonna just in the in the flash
in the blink of an eye be like we need
you know 5 000 living adult humans to
figure out what how X does y or
something and there will be literal
people just completely treated like
cabbage garbage so if you're gonna get
to that point with AI though you guys
should because Moore's law has been
slowing down read which one the art
elector by Hilo degaris yeah it's my
favorite book in the whole world isn't
that like a really hard to get book or
something uh yeah it's like a thousand
dollars on Amazon I will let you borrow
my coffee
that's like a third the price of a
textbook yeah that's pretty good yeah
but it's it's written it's a really
interesting book this guy
um actually is pro robot takeover but he
he does present both sides very well
um and they call it the artelect war
where it'll be like
is that available right now once once
yeah so once once we hit the like
Moore's law was like oh it's you know
every two years of doubles yeah and then
they're like oh no the the it's it you
know everything's getting too small and
the electrons are popping in and out
they just start adding up more chords
they're also moving away from using
electricity and and shifting to light in
in circuitry or Quantum Computing yeah
so also this assumes that Civil Society
exists long enough for AI to be
developed it's gonna be they're going to
be paying women to get pregnant and just
be there and giving birth over and over
and over that'll be their job I don't
think yeah if there's an AI in charge it
will be harvesting humans no we've
talked about this before the AI humans
so there will be Untold cruelty because
cruelty doesn't exist in the mind of the
machine trying to find them most
efficient end but a lot of what would
happen this is nightmarish so first we
talked about algorithmic psychosis on
this channel quite a bit how people go
on social media and then just get fed a
rotating cycle of insane content which
makes them go insane over a certain
amount of time
what people don't realize you really got
to look at how AIS develop things they
don't do exactly what you intend them to
YouTube so so that's true but to be fair
Ai and algorithms are fairly different
but just for rudimentary's argument
YouTube says here are the parameters by
which we want this system to feed
content to people and what they're
hoping for was Game of Thrones longer
form content with high engagement what
do they get they got the Incredible Hulk
and Hitler doing Tai Chi and Hitler's
head was on a bikini body and it's
singing a nursery rhymes okay but to be
fair I wouldn't that's don't belittle
that compared to the Avengers all right
bro like that's really elitist of you to
say one is better than the other oh oh
for sure but here's what I'm saying
awesome apply that principle to an
algorithmically run Society in any
capacity or an AI that is
exponentially developing what will
happen is it's it's you will have
nothing but corn and then one day all of
a sudden like everything in the
supermarket is just corn and you're like
why where's the milk where's it it just
corn replace everything because the AI
was like corns faster and easier to make
and if we make more of it it's easier to
make more at one time and then all of a
sudden you have no resource everyone
starves well I mean so the problem with
AI theoretically would be the same
problem that we have with anything
humans construct whether it's an
algorithm whether it's public policy
there are laws there's the law of
unintended consequences anytime humans
try to set up a structure to get a
certain kind of behavior from a person
or a group of people they end up with
something other than what they were
shooting for sometimes it's successful
but I'm not sure if you've heard of the
Cobra effect or if I've ever talked
about this on the show so there was I
can't even remember the country I
actually I believe this was in British
occupied India
and there were Cobra infestations and so
what they did was they said we will pay
people for every Cobra tell that they
bring us because then they'll be out
there killing cobras they have an
economic incentive to do so to bring the
carcasses to us we'll give them money
what happened was people started finding
male and female cobras and starting
breeding operations yeah
they could bring them to the British
government
so the popular
there's a there's a story I was reading
on Reddit and they said that they Pro
they programmed an AI to play Tetris
hoping to see highest level play like
level 100 it's going so fast you can't
even see the screen you know what the AI
did
just quit got bored and started playing
Mario the goal the goal was to see
to generate an AI that could play Tetris
for as long as possible
so what do you think it did pause the
game yes oh my gosh pause the game path
of least resistance that's right and so
we're thinking it's going to play and
then also it pauses and we're like wait
what oh man we gotta change that brand
so I'll tell you this I think we've
talked about the AI future where I've
said like you know you'll wake up and
your phone will vibrate and it'll be
like free credit opportunity and it'll
say walk outside and yell and then
you'll you'll be like okay you'll go
outside and you'll yell and then it'll
go accomplish but Ding and then it'll
give you credits and then there'll be
another guy walking on the street and
he'll be like turn left here and you
know uh pick pick up this this strange
object from this man and you'll walk by
and you'll see the guy in his picture
and I'll hand you a weird black orb and
you'll go okay and then it'll say now
walk three feet hand it to the woman and
you do but then you get credits because
what's happening is wherever you are and
you're walking the AI has found a method
of delivering that object that it needs
to a certain area faster than you just
going and doing it so you're getting
these random instructions you don't
quite understand
the scary thing is eventually someone's
going to get get one that's gonna be
like turn left here and they're gonna
fall off a cliff and then they're gonna
into the ground and holding the orb and
then someone walks up and picks up the
orb from the carcass and walks away
because Ann doesn't value you as an
individual
yeah AI future man what if they code it
what if they put if going to have
someone walk off building then stop
remember when Apple Maps came out some
lady drove into a lake because
apparently oh my gosh that's right she
was driving a throwback she was driving
on the road and it said turn left here
and she went okay
remember that no when Michael drives
into the lake I think the GPS tells him
too there was a that's probably where
they got a true story there was one lady
who drove like 500 miles into the desert
because it told her to turn right here
and she did and then she rented a guess
and she's in the middle of nowhere like
I don't know where I am and because the
computer told her to do it she did it
that Siri didn't like how she was
talking she's like I know what I'm doing
can I just stress this is GPS this is
not even like something running your
life it's literally just a map you can
look at and be like that's bringing me
to the desert I'm not gonna go there and
people still do it yeah man what do you
think's gonna happen when we start
getting more and more robots to replace
more and more of Our Lives dude I had my
GPS recently tell me to take a U-turn
immediately after merging onto the
highway when there was when there was a
barrier between between the sides of the
highway that you can drive on so like
literally it was just telling me to kill
myself
people do it people do this pretty rude
it's going to be uh unfun but uh and
then you know what's the best part I
just went onto the highway normal like
and then in order to get me off the
highway and turn around it like
specifically had me go through two tolls
well that's rude it's like I started to
think this is on purpose man see that's
the other thing too
GPS ever do weird stuff with tolls
because I've had other people share
similar stories I don't I don't know if
it's intentional but uh it's you Sheamus
that's probably sorry we gotta make sure
AI stays as advisors and not as
commanders it's too late bro I don't
know we've already got computer programs
that that tell us what to do with our
with our day
sometimes I'm wearing the watch and then
in the middle of the day it'll vibrate
and then it shows a little man who's
like middle middle age like a
middle-aged kind of tubby guy and he's
like doing like you know this or
whatever and going like that and it's
like time to get up and I'm like Tim
literally does exactly that I literally
does that little movie it happened it's
crazy I get lovian response the little
man says it's time to start moving and I
get up and I walk around and I go
outside and then it gives me a little
thing like an award
downloaded the footage of the little guy
doing that and whenever I play it Tim
just involuntarily starts doing the
workout he's been so conditioned well
because the watch says I have to do it
yeah well you have to you can't not
listen to the watch I know I think we'll
have to make sure that following AR
instructions gives you reward incentives
as opposed to punishment for disobeying
well but I think that wouldn't work
that's just Brave New World exactly
thank you yeah it's I think it's more in
cities you trust it more when it's just
a reward Brave New World versus
yeah do you want your your do you want
your happiness medicine or your video
game much rather have you have the
happiness medicine this is what that's
what you're getting right now I know
when you're when you're staring at your
phone you're getting those dopamine hits
you're seeing the likes and the retweets
and you're like oh man you gotta break
that spell man it's here no I'm saying
like I am the first to admit I have a
problem with it it's difficult when you
make any of your living on social media
you have this justification for looking
at it and engaging with your audience
but it's really easy to justify an
addiction that way there's a really
simple way to break the addiction to
likes and Views and retweets you just
need to have several million followers
100 million views in a single exactly
once I get there once but no no but in
all honestly once there's nowhere left
to go you lose all reward triggering
from the entire system and you lose any
and all emotion related to any of it
that's what I'm hoping for to just lose
all of my emotions but no I I hear you
like I feel like if you hit a plateau
that's sort of what happens it's not
it's not a plateau it's like when when
you when you've climbed the top of the
highest mountain what do you do next you
know eventually just like well that was
fun you know we see all right but here's
what I would like I know knowing myself
I would try to expand in other things
because you know I'm already doing that
I I work with other clients I try to
produce videos from different
organizations so I'll always be like I
have to keep sure what I'm saying is
most people on uh on YouTube there's a
YouTube depression thing that happens
because views are seasonal especially
food for a show like so true yeah so the
politics they are so we're we're a news
politic I think this is actually Tim
cast iron society and culture but uh Tim
full Daily Show is news so views go way
down and everyone right now is like haha
CNN's viewership is in the gutter and
I'm like yeah but I'm like it's not
that's not funny guys with someone for
that CNN's General news so their views
shouldn't be this bad Brian stelter's
like checking he's like refreshing yeah
they couldn't break him in his YouTube
they couldn't get CNN couldn't break a
million views that's wrong or whatever
so the point is but it were in the Down
Season there's no election this year
there's no primary so so next year's
election things start kicking back up
but what happens to a lot of these
YouTubers is they notice their views are
going down they have panic attacks they
start freaking out like what are my
number is low this is bad and they feel
like they're losing because they don't
understand break the spell dude it's not
real no that's true that's right I've
gotten better at that because they're
like over the past year especially I
feel like I've had a lot of like it is a
weird way of putting it but steady ups
and downs it hasn't been all over the
place but it's like oh we're doing real
good and then oh not so good then really
good again and so it's gotten to the
point where I don't worry about it too
much but I think it has to happen to you
again about it it has to happen to you
enough to the point where you know not
to be concerned when you're in those
dips we just need to educate kids about
this stuff before they get into it yeah
yeah a couple years ago it was like in
May and I put up a video and the views
were just in the gutter and I was like
did I do something wrong May was bad for
me too is is the video not entertaining
like what's happening and I was like
well I'll tell you what you can't win
them all yeah right so so I'm like you
know what I did my best I shot my shot
and I'll just keep working tomorrow and
I don't let the little things hold me me
up went out to eat and all of a sudden I
we went out everywhere we went was
packed every restaurant every Diner why
and I was like guys get back inside and
watch my videos that you're exactly
right they were outside yeah and so then
I thought about it and I looked up it
had been raining the entire week and so
everybody was inside watching your
watching your videos your views are good
and then the sunny spring day happens
yeah all of the families wanted to go
out to eat in the nice weather that's
what they're not about them to watch
videos it's a song Where I Come From
rain is a good thing it's about a
YouTuber when people are inside watching
the videos
oh sorry no good I I just want to
mention one more thing because it's on
this topic
we have not you mentioned we should be
teaching kids about this stuff and it's
so crazy because we have no idea how to
navigate social media in a truly healthy
way and it's not just social media it's
instant connection and communication so
I was thinking about this a while ago if
you had some kind of universal PA system
in cars the way truckers have them where
you can just communicate with other
truckers people would immediately start
killing each other Road wage would get
horrible like if people no no hold on
this this exists I know Tesla's starting
to no no no no no it's it's like ancient
technology bro no no that's what I'm
saying they could do it very easily but
no no no no no no
you can talk yes every single car what
you're talking about engine technology a
powerful enough broadcaster will will
broadcast sound from any speaker yeah
yeah so you you can literally uh if if
you have the broadcast right I'm pretty
sure that's illegal to do so don't do it
yeah but if you had a powerful
broadcaster you could literally pull up
next to a car and broadcast through
their speakers whether they wanted you
wanted it's not an issue of frequencies
around or anything it's that the signal
hits the speaker itself and sends the
sound out my point is Tesla's talked
about implementing this with Tesla and
truckers have it oh yeah the
infrastructure for actually talking with
the other cars on the road next to you
where it's part of the status quo you're
not doing anything illegal we don't do
this and I suspect part of it is because
that would distract drivers and it would
also be horrific in terms of road rage
you think about the way people talk to
each other on the internet when they
think they're Anonymous imagine when
you're on the highway with people you
never think you're going to see again I
think it would cause a lot of problems
and that's a relatively Simple
Technology you look at social media and
how much that's affected us the fact
that we were completely unprepared for
it and it was just dropped on us we have
no rules for it I I want to say I feel
really bad for kids today you know why
yes people never know the joy of rushing
full speed to the wall mounted phone as
you race your sibling to try and answer
it first that's true because you want to
know who's calling or then a commercial
break when it rings and then it's your
brother or sister who answers it you're
like who is it was it and it's like it's
like the bank calling and like who cares
they're asking if I have time to take a
survey not to be fair when you have like
YouTube TV or one of these networks like
you still run in the bathroom when the
commercial comes on yeah for sure but
but I guess the other thing I wanted to
mention is it's not even just social
media you look at the instant
communication that we have with our cell
phones SMS you have an obligation to
upkeep relationships with people when
you're not even seeing them that day
people will be upset with you for not
texting them back quickly enough in the
past it was completely normal to go a
day or two without having conversations
with people who you were close to but
now it's constant and people will even
be upset if you're not giving them space
in your life and attention when you're
not with them that day you know you so
you know Ian yeah I'm sure everybody
here understands this I remember it's
like I'm a little kid and I'm going to
my friend's house gonna go see if
they're home walk across the alley
because you know our friend lives on the
other on the next street over so you
walk through the alley go to the house
knock on the door there's no answer and
I go I guess I'm not gonna hang out with
them today and that was it yeah and then
and someday some days I'd answer in
there and and my friend's mom would
answer and I'd be like you know is my
friend home she'd be like oh he's uh
he's at the park I'm gonna go to the
park and I go there no one's there and
then I'm like nobody's here I got them
at the park now by myself that was it
that was life no cell phones I caught
the very tale end of that like I you
know I didn't have a cell phone as a kid
or anything like that I wasn't until
high school but oh these Adventures dude
yeah I remember when I was a kid just
like going out to my my friend's house
or calling them on the landline asking
their parents if they were home it's
like Dr Manhattan you know in in
Watchmen when uh he's he's he's at the
final Antarctic Fortress or whatever and
Ozzy men Diaz has been sending tachyons
to obstruct Dr Manhattan's future site
and then he says you know he's like I
want to thank you I'd almost forgotten
the joy of not knowing bro before the
internet before cell phones life was an
adventure you didn't know where you were
going or why you were going there we'd
like walk down the old Freight tracks
and then find like an old abandoned
shipping yeah I don't know this now it's
like the map just shows you the whole
time and you're like I knew that was
there it's not fun yeah no I missed no
Adventure I miss it but I'm sorry
Cassandra you were going to say
something oh it's okay it's not relevant
anymore just say it I want to hear it
it's okay are you sure yeah okay we're
way past that when did you get internet
for the first time time
um I had it in elementary school at my
grandparents house I would go on AOL
dial up oh my God my favorite noise
not on dos bro what did you what do you
know nothing my
um my Asian family was very
technologically advanced I see that yeah
yes well let me tell you about my Irish
family not super technology yeah okay I
thought you were gonna say something
else very technologically advanced what
do you think I was gonna say some kind
of offensive stereotype I'll have none
of it I'll have none of it Timothy as
you're going to mention whiskey I have
nothing and I'll have none I thought Mr
Timothy cast I thought you were gonna
say that your family were prestigious
and uh well-renowned distillers of fine
yeah whiskeys not drunks at all excuse
me I'm also Irish yeah you can make some
of these jokes I guess I like that I
like that Family Guy but your passing is
non-irish you know so like you don't
understand the oppression
I like the family I joke where it's like
he land that the plane lands in Ireland
and there's beer bottles in the runway
and then this has something like you
know he's like Ireland was a very
different place before the invention of
alcohol and then it flashes back to like
but it's actually a futuristic Society
with flying cars yeah and scientist
comes in and he's like look they
invented out whiskey and they all
started beating each other up
yeah I guess it's not true though the
The Stereotype of Irish is being drunk
has never been true that's never been
true it was a propaganda thing Patrick
promised no I've never even met I've
never met an Irish person with a
drinking problem once it's true I
haven't either not one of them lying
I've never met an Irish person who BS
either Tim never that's that's not even
a thing I don't dude I'm gonna be honest
there's a lot of Truth to that
stereotype there's a lot of Truth to The
Stereotype of Irish people drinking a
lot I gotta be real The Paddy Wagon I
don't I don't know what PC nonsense
you've been hearing but it's it's a
thing it is so uh Britney Spears is
Catholic Britney Spears is Catholic yes
this is incredible I knew that as soon
as they brought it up Sheamus was going
to be like oh yeah
oh we got a white pill today I'm
actually really happy to hear this no
I'm really happy to hear this I learned
about it on social media the other day
and lamentably never brought it up on
the podcast I don't know why what
happened she just posted about how she's
Catholic now and she just got back for
math so good for her wow I'm very happy
for you I really do think that is that
that is good for especially everything
she's been through with her family and
all this Insanity I've been playing a
lot of Rim world and in the game if you
put someone in like a dark cage and they
have a psychotic break sometimes they'll
have a shift of Faith thanks buddy
so maybe that's what she maybe that's
what she just experienced wow I've got
to say I support the free Brittany
movement and stuff I think that you know
what's happened to her is terrible but
I've been so frustrated watching
Republicans like clamor to defend
Britney Spears when we have political
prisoners who are sitting in jail since
January 6th we have Julian Assange
sitting in prison we have all these
political prisoners and they're like
free Brittany guys yeah but I think
we were talking about like unborn
children being killed but then also you
care about animal rights I think I think
The Unborn children thing is
significantly more important but that
doesn't mean it's wrong for you to be as
informed as you are about Peta I
remember back in 2018 when I said
Republicans were too stupid to deal with
social media censorship to save their
own careers also and like all these
Republican voters are like yes like the
Republican party what do they do no it's
amazing it's like ilhan Omar can come
out and win word vomit all over a group
of people and then the Democrats are
like well now let's not be too hasty and
then Marjorie Taylor green posts
something before getting elected and
they're all like let's stripper of her
her committees and punish her because
the Republicans are losers yeah there's
a couple of them you know what's funny I
was thinking about Rhino like you know
people call them rhinos yeah Republicans
name only but they but they'll say like
oh Mitch McConnell's a rhino I'm like no
he isn't he's exactly the Republican
party oh bro that's so true Rand Paul
Thomas Massey they're the ones who stand
out yeah that's very true no you're
right you're right I got to give that to
you yeah they're the ones who are like
this was our past in to actually affect
real positive change the Republican
party doesn't do anything they just I
don't know sit in their hands yeah and
then they attack the ones who do try to
do anything yeah well this is the
creator they're the the you know we like
to say that they're the speed bump for
the Democrats but they're more like The
Gatekeepers making sure that nobody gets
in the way and allows the Democrats to
do whatever they want yes exactly
welcome to the uni party yep well this
is the thing too because a lot of people
I know on the left tend to not like the
Democratic party either I basically
don't know anyone who likes their
political party I agree frankly uh and
maybe that's just because I wouldn't
hang out with someone who did like their
political party and so it's a sampling
bias uh Libertarians libertarian party
Libertarians don't like the lp they've
been living
back when I was libertarian I hated the
lp the whole time I do I'm not a fan
but the mises caucus exactly yes Dave
Smith they're the only good thing as far
as I'm concerned
watching their pro-life watching Dave
Smith on Fox News is just amazing when
he debates leftists and they're like
Donald Trump and he's like I didn't vote
for him I don't like him I love it he's
like I think Trump is a war yes all the
time he's like yeah he does they can't
these tribalist established people can't
handle it they're like I don't you you
you're clearly a trump supporter it's
like no there's a Libertarian we're not
you know what I mean that's what they're
saying yeah that that's actually given
me some uh you know I don't know white
pill I guess you can call it but I guess
the bigger question is whether or not
the libertarian party can pull off any
victories I really think it would be an
incredible thing if we had at least one
libertarian Party candidate in the in in
the house or something like that that's
my point I don't really
I don't really want them in well it's
complicated here's the thing I've said
this before my whole voting strategy is
vote for the most pragmatic pro-life
candidate possible and it gets difficult
when the libertarian party's involved in
a national election and they split up
the vote but honestly I think local
elections are unbelievably important if
not more important and if you've got a
pro-life libertarian again even though I
don't consider myself libertarian
anymore oftentimes they're going to be a
better option than a republican now of
course again you get into this issue of
splitting up the vote but that's not
always the case and it depends
Libertarians I don't know I don't know
Libertarians no I don't like
Libertarians at all so I think that they
they're they're good on foreign policy
and stuff like that but we have a
massive crisis with the culture
domestically right amen and they're like
let people be as degenerate as they want
some of them are like the hopians though
Story Hour yeah as far as I'm aware the
hopping like the mises caucus people are
not like that oh my God I'm not
liberating anymore yeah I support the
the mises
well so in general I'm not a fan of
Libertarians basically libertarian party
is a disaster yeah and then some sane
Libertarians came out and they were like
we're gonna form a caucus because we're
not insane misus is a guy right yeah
saluted fungus so yes the the I think
too much of libertarianism it's that
Meme of the Fox right you know the
scraggly looking Fox and it's like
that's what libertarian ideals is the
beautiful Fox right the candidates are
all like scraggly and weird the majority
of them are open borders they support
allowing things like drag queen Story
Hour oh I've seen a lot of them
supporting CRT and I mean yeah those
people those people are idiots yeah like
you're great on foreign policy cool but
like we have some problems here right
now so I hear you yeah but but you can
be libertarian and be opposed to those
things and that's the problem with
Libertarians they ruined libertarianism
well the party the party itself the
party is garbage it's terrible so if you
guys want like libertarian party people
elected I have to disagree no well
that's what I'm saying if you had good
people like like from the mises caucus
in the party who are actually gonna
stand up against the federal government
when they try to impose these lockdowns
on their County which I think
Libertarians in the mises caucus would
be far more likely to do than
Republicans then I would say okay that's
a good person to vote for yeah but if
we're talking about these sort of milk
tea milk toast people who are in favor
of garbage like CRT and say like drag
queen Story Hour is just the right yeah
you have a right to like force your
perversion onto children take his
clothes off on stage yes yep yep that
did happen what is this that indeed can
we get sane liberty-minded individuals
well we we do I think with music caucus
but yeah I think
um the problem is there are a lot of
anarcho-capitalists they're absolutely
on on board with all that stuff now that
they're on board with it because I don't
know Smith is it yeah they're really
weird about the age of consent stuff too
I like really don't like them I don't
know you can be on the libertarian
spectrum and want individual freedoms
and Liberties while recognizing we need
standards yeah I mean like we I don't I
don't want the idea of the scraggly
degenerate you know Fox libertarian
ruining the idea of respecting
individual liberties and being in the
Liberty side you know the problem is
people who are for Liberty tend to be
more individualist and don't organize
Yep they're like leave me alone I'll do
my thing and then what happens right
everything goes insane and the lunatics
table they often don't get into politics
I can't bring myself to do it I think
it's technology is the way if you really
are liberty-minded sane individual you
should be building technology that will
help solve like social media algorithm
problems you know shipping and materials
so that we can get drone deliveries
organized all over the world
we're not going to write our way out of
this with politics
what's up I had an MRE earlier how was
it was pretty good salty people were
eating yeah yeah because they're because
they're fun it's like Lunchables for
adults because you eat one last night
too
um I think I think I did there's like an
open one on the bar I may have yeah it's
a lot of yeah I had tuna I had Tuna the
Tuna was good what made you think of it
I don't know I just burped oh yeah I was
like yeah that's good that means you're
digesting something hey earlier when I
said that uh psychotic break can make
you have a crisis of faith I wasn't
saying that it's psychotic I was being I
was being Sergeant I'm saying that guy
when people go through psychotic breaks
they they have shifts of Faith sometimes
maybe Brittany who's been locked up and
going insane all of a sudden had a
crisis of Faith or maybe her faith was
like Faith was something she needed to
get through that yeah maybe because she
wasn't Catholic before right now she is
is that I mean she was Christian she may
have been a lapsed Catholic or something
like no she was yeah she also said she
said I'm Catholic now not like I'm
taking my faith seriously or so uh I
assume she was not Catholic before maybe
maybe we need to start thinking about
things more like Vermin Supreme did yeah
let's go deeper on that of just like
absurdity to challenge the system yeah
organize absurdity organized absurdity I
like this idea
yeah I like the Andy Kaufman it's called
government exists it's called the DNC so
so here's a funny thing like uh antifa
used to be just just be called the black
block and it was a nebulous term to ref
it was just a reference to the group of
people who all wear you know all black
and garan's matching stuff which is
basically called antifuno and there were
a lot of people like trying to figure
out how do you deal with that they're
like what's it what's a counter to this
because if you show up and like into a
fight with them they'll call you far
right or whatever and I was like boom
clowns yes clown block show up yeah just
for the sake of entertainment to dance
and sing and play music and clap and and
do uh that's how you defuse the violence
from these extremists I just got a
unicycle perfect breathing fire
imagine this imagine this antifa's going
like they're all smashing and screaming
imagine that and then like you know the
right wing groups show up and they're
fighting and they have Shields and
there's the news it's like oh no there's
clash in the street imagine instead a
bunch of clowns stood up and they were
they came with flowers and they were
dancing and happy and they were getting
in the way of the extremists and they
were going in between the Black Block
how are you going to say a bunch of
clowns the bad guys when they're there
with flowers and they're laughing and
playing music and dancing and everyone's
just like it breaks that violence apart
I I honestly I gotta say I think that
could stop a riot you see antifa going
out there and they're smashing windows
and screaming sending the clowns you
know what else to stop a riot if we put
all these people back into asylums bring
back Asylum
no I I'm a big fan of Exile
because it's a personal thing right like
if some if if they can't if Society came
to me and said what you're doing is
wrong and we want to lock you up for it
I'd be like can I take a boat and just
go off and do my own thing because I'd
rather do that I'd rather risk my own
yeah I think they banished uh Lenin from
Russia or from Soviet Union and they
banished Napoleon from France but they
both came back like worse than ever
Napoleon came back and started another
war and then and so did Lenin came you
know I was thinking about this I'm like
what would we do for like healthcare
reform and prison reform and I was like
we should totally get rid of our prisons
as we know it and maybe just create like
um what do they do in Norway it's like
an island yeah it is they put everyone
on an island interesting and then like
you get limited resources and you're
basically responsible for yourself and I
I think there's a study that said they
actually found that it eliminated the
criminal Tendencies because people
started working together to survive good
for them and it you know I'm like maybe
that's a better way to do it instead of
having people in these institutionalized
you know penitentiaries where they're
not actually being rehabilitated they're
being institutionalized we let people
you know we obviously monitor health and
safety we don't we're not sending people
to an island just starve to death but
it's like your day is your day you're
responsible for yourself you can't leave
we won't let you but you're free to roam
as you please and there would be housing
and then it's just like there you go
we've we've removed the threat from
society and now you're off over there
doing whatever you want
I think they would form like militias
and and abuse there's no weapons yeah
surrounded by walls are they allowed to
like throw the pedophiles off the
buildings or what what's the deal like
do they have police no no like no prison
guards
if you're a violent criminal no there
would be food they would give them food
if you're a violent Criminal
you then through due process you lose
some rights you lose many of your rights
and I think why should we spend so much
money locking them in these big
facilities desperately trying to contain
the threat instead of being like you
have forfeited you know the social
contract and we're gonna send you over
there and you can go do whatever you
want just not here with us yeah I think
it's prison exacerbates the problem a
lot of times they go sit there with
other criminals and a violent
environment what if we make them and
hear me out you know they're they're in
these tunnels and they stand on this
pedestal that raises them up and then
there's you know 20 23 other people and
there's in the middle a bunch of weapons
and they're in this big dome yes and
then the countdown happens and then
whoever survives in the end wins and is
called the Victor and then they can do
that every onto Society
I'm kidding by the way you earn your
freedom if you kill the most people you
earn your freedom oh that's like the
movie Gamer you've seen Gamers yeah I
like that movie with um Gerard Butler
that's the dude from 300. yeah he's
amazing yeah the movie was cool all of
my favorite actors of all time oh
they're bringing Dexter back yeah
they're filming it in Massachusetts wow
I'm kind of excited for that because
Dexter was awesome but it like ended you
know but the ending was bad yeah okay so
I'm kind of okay with the new new end
did you see Suicide Squad
no because I am very still upset about
yeah what they did to Suicide Squad
this is my favorite comic oh brutal
partial spoiler I'm not I'm not going to
spoil any anything from the movie
but if you don't want to hear anything
about the movie then you're not going to
want to hear what I have to say my
critique of it
uh so you've been warned
hold on thank you
I didn't I didn't I didn't really enjoy
it I I'll say this I laughed a lot
um but I think I realized something
James Gunn doesn't have the magic Kevin
feige does and James Gunn has some good
ideas that when put through the Marvel
Studios filter making made an excellent
movie but I was really confused as to
why they did Suicide Squad this one the
way they did now apparently it's getting
Rey reviews they did it they redeemed
themselves I'm like no they didn't no no
they didn't was uh Jared Leto in that
and then okay he he was apparently
didn't take that one very seriously I'm
really banned from Ever playing The
Joker ever I'm really really really mad
about something in Suicide Squad as soon
as this one thing happened I almost
turned it off why would you say this
yeah is this new the news yeah it just
came out
um uh came out like what is it like yeah
this morning like midnight oh yeah oh
you already you saw it you were watching
it yeah it's on HBO Max dude I it's
funny because I like took my headphones
off and put my fingers in my ears but I
was like wait a minute because I hate
having things spoiled but I was like I'm
never gonna watch this wait a second I
was I was like The Wheels On The Bus
Tim's going on about suicide squad I
don't I I I don't wanna I don't want to
say it's too soon to say spoilers I
can't even talk about spoilers too soon
it literally just came out so I'll have
to wait you advise people to go see it
yeah yeah it was it was it would I
definitely think you really have a fun
time go to the movies grab some popcorn
and sit back the first one
I okay I was amped for that movie I
bought it was sold out uh so I had
bought like three different showings of
it I got an outfit for it because I like
love Suicide Squad I love anything
involving the Joker and so I was amped
and then I went and saw it and I was
just like me and like five other people
that were random people that were in the
theater were screaming at it like and I
hate that guy I hate the person who
screams at the movie theater but we were
like throwing our popcorn it was that it
was who's your favorite joke
um Joaquin Phoenix
so you like the northern Heath Ledger
yeah wow definitely
possible dude when I I definitely
enjoyed it but it's it's tough for me
when I watched Joker that last scene
where he's sitting there and he's
talking to you know what's his favorite
murder and he goes I'm the Joker baby
I'm I'm like on the edge of my seat and
I'm shaking like watching it like I like
my heart was racing I was like this is
amazing and it's well done it was for us
for a super villain and it was not your
typical super super villain I was just
like the ending blew me out of my scene
I saw it twice in a row opening night
the first one yeah my problem with it
was that there was no Batman there was
no villain in that movie it was called
Joker not bad like Batman would have
been the villain actually
Batman isn't it I mean Bruce Bruce there
is a villain there's Murray there's uh
Bruce Wayne yeah
I don't know I'd like to see why I play
The Joker in the Batman movie well
they're they're doing that would be cool
I agree in the flash Michael Keaton's
coming back I guess yeah Michael
Keaton's gonna be playing Batman in The
Flash movie which is awesome Michael
Keaton by the way also I think the best
Marvel villain to be complete Adrian
tombs did you guys see uh he was good
homecoming no it was one of the best of
villains I've seen in any of the Marvel
movies he's so real A working class guy
doing cleanup on a contract he already
bought the gear and then the the
government comes in and says you're out
and he's like come on guys like we
already bought the equipment like we got
to pay this off I got people to feed and
they're like so what and so he gets
screwed over by the government and he
becomes this like
I'm gonna take whatever I have to take
kind of villain it was good it was good
yeah the new Joker is based off uh
Bernie Getz did you guys know that I
didn't know that recently he was um it
was a really big case that the NRA had
got involved with
um he killed or he shot I don't remember
if he killed them but he shot some
people on the subway and was basically
like I'm sick of crime I took it into my
own hands he was the Vigilant the subway
vigilante guy yeah
sung about in We Didn't Start the Fire
by yes Billy Joel who looks like Michael
Keaton
I always thought he did what ever since
I was a kid in the 80s he looked up I
thought they were made that was back
when the NRA had guts anyway John Cena
right John Cena and Suicide Squad I
thought was pretty good oh I was I was
really I thought it was great he was
he's funny he's good he's good John
Cena's great yeah that was that was rad
and Idris Elba pretty good uh but I I
was I almost turned it off margarubian
again yes she's like the face of the
movie basically just I just I almost
couldn't watch it I was I was angry damn
I was like I can't believe they would do
this YouTube but they're making a new
alien they're just abusing these titles
now it's true yeah man well how about we
go to super chats yes super chats if you
haven't already give us a Super Chat
smash that like button subscribe to the
channel go to timcast.com become a
member we've got uh some new shows in
the works hopefully soon
um oh so you know like uh the mystery
show I got so much to tell you Cassandra
yeah we got a ton of stuff uh being done
we've got people tons of people working
on it we've had a bunch of really great
stories and uh for those that are
listening it is coming The Branding is
is we're working on the artwork and I
think you'll get a kick out of The Vibes
we're going for so anyway let's read
some of these super chats Matthew
Hammond says Cassandra is the best and
needs her own timcast.com show please
make this happen Tim her typed words are
not enough I hate being on camera and I
only agree to this because Tim said that
I could bully PETA
I was like Cassandra would you like to
come on the show Friday and she just
kind of talk about Pete and I was like
of course
did we like finish talking about Peter
did was there more you were going to
talk I could talk about them all night
yeah you were really good I'm surprised
you don't like being on camera their
lawyer Jerry Goodman he uh
he's my mortal enemy now so
I gotta I gotta I gotta read this one
Jurassic Josh says Alex Jones quote
human animal hybrids are real mainstream
media while hiding the rat with a baby's
scalp nah bro you crazy yeah they
actually call him chimeras well they
aren't they growing human organs and
pigs probably I heard about that for
sure they ruled against it Democrats did
remember oh yeah that's right offshore
or something now they got to pay a
company to do it for them do you guys
ever watch the island Isle of Dr Moreau
oh God you imagine just like a facility
full of like weird like animal people
there's I watch some kind of like
conspiracy documentary that claimed that
there's something like that in the U.S
once and I was really really into it but
this is years ago and I can't remember
what it was but it was interesting just
in like the weird like I mean you watch
it thinking like this isn't probably
isn't true but it's interesting to watch
right
um yeah they were claiming that they
were like goat people and stuff now I'm
like oh maybe yeah
all right let's see
Jesse Meek says love your show can't
catch it live often shout out to your
entire crew you all never fail to
impress especially you Lydia sorry I
can't help your Twitter ratings I do not
social media shout out to Liberty doll
also please I understand don't do so
don't do social media
media Nan uh najma says in California if
a woman is murdered while she's pregnant
it's considered a double homicide no
matter how far along she is wow is that
true yeah that is correct I will look
this up but yeah I remember hearing that
um because I was saying something from
Rand Paul and he said you know he was an
OB GYN life begins at conception and
then someone mentioned to someone argued
with it saying it's not true and they
were like in California it's a double
homicide how can they justify that being
true but then argue the inverse when it
comes to abortion it's like you can't
have it both ways great question you
know no actually that would have been a
good point to ask vosh when he was here
because he said he was asked when when
does he think life begins his I don't
know birth maybe it's like okay well
then do you think California should
repeal its law about double homicide
that's you know the case
drummer rat says I was born at 23 weeks
knowing they're doing abortions after
that time frame is sickening to me wow
wow doing them at all good for you you
made it
some of these I can't read but I I love
the righteous indignation
well I'm glad people are fired up about
this yeah that's right and you know what
if you're fired up about this please
don't limit it to a Super Chat go you
know go out there and tell people about
this talk about this go talk to people
organize
um call your call your your your
Congress people your senators make those
phone calls man because I'll tell you
this people don't realize that stuff
works it does yeah like imagine you you
look these people are trying to figure
out what gets them elected yep and if
and if someone's fired up it's like what
was it was it Family Guy where they're
like we received seven phone calls
complaining about last night that means
seven billion people are upset well
that's that's how they work like if a
congressperson gets like 50 phone calls
they're gonna be like this is this is
lighting people up this is crazy yeah
exactly and so Congress people are in
some sense easy to control for the same
reason that the American people are easy
to control no one cultivates virtue they
take the path of least resistance
whatever they have to do to preserve
their status quo is something they're
going to be willing to do so if they
feel that their political career is
contingent upon them opposing the
dismemberment of unborn children humans
being used for scientific research then
they might just be against it so please
write your letters unless you're
addicted to losing do something about
this I would like to issue a legitimate
apology to people who are upset by
hearing everything we talk about but
just hope you understand that we need to
talk about it
archangel762 says thanks Tim I was in a
good mood until I heard this but more
people should know this is happening
that's that's the reality you know it's
like do we do we only talk about candy
canes and rainbows and movies or are we
like the front line talking about some
of the darkest things so that people can
go watch movies and not have to worry
about it you have to do well they do
have to worry about it well here's the
thing we talk about political issues all
the time it's culture and politics and
we also talk about some pretty serious
issues and we were able to make light of
it or joke about it sometimes make it
entertaining but there are some things
that are so serious you can't really
joke about them you can't make it funny
it's just going to bring everybody's
mood down but we still got to talk about
that stuff Dark Days man jmax says it's
convenience man will sell his soul to
make life a little less hard yes how
many people complain about Amazon right
and left alike but they're dropping that
stimulus check on new shoes shipped
right to their door yep that is a true
yeah
it's it's it's difficult to Source all
of these things you know it's like how
much time do we have in the day it's
it's Amazon's made it so easy they're
siphoning off resources the greatest
wealth transfer in history did you hear
what Bezos said when he came back from
space and he's like thanks you paid for
it
and it's you know why we paid for it
because everybody's small business got
shut down because of these ridiculous
lockdowns and so we weren't able to
patronize people in our neighborhoods
who had built businesses up from scratch
and contributed our community so we had
to buy it from you
that's why we paid for it thank you Mr
Bezos or I should say you're welcome
Tree Brokers as I work on farms every
day there is no such thing as factory
farms that made up Lefty definition if
you'd like to talk about it hit me up
all right well I'm whatever you want to
call it I have seen the Farms where the
conditions are horrible and I've seen
the Farms where the conditions are
fantastic I I can drive around this area
and every single Farm is beautiful like
a fairy tale no joke it's like so much
fun one of them has like llamas
but you can pull right up and it's like
it's like five bucks and they walk up to
the llamas because they know people love
llamas so much think about that for a
farm they're like people want to see
this so much they'll pay us just to
stand here but then look at some of
these other Farms where it's all dirt
and mud and they're loaded up and it's
like call that whatever you want to call
it but no one's going to be going there
to to pet the muddy diseased animals oh
how sad yeah
there'll be pools of feces and blood
giant pools of it outside where they
like wash everything off with a hose and
it just soaks into the ground rot water
and contaminates and they won't let
drones fly overhead to take pictures
this is absolute disgust this is the
amazing thing about the Farms I went to
in California where the cows could do
whatever they wanted because I was like
do you milk them and he's like they go
in the machine and I was like what he's
like yeah because it it's too much milk
it hurts them so they go in the machine
in the machine just you know gets the
milk out for him and I was like really
he's like yeah they love it and all the
cows were like jumping up and down they
were happy they were like hanging out
and having friends and I was like Wow in
New Zealand it was like that too I drove
from Auckland to Wellington New Zealand
there's just cows and sheep everywhere
and they're they're they're just happy
as can be man it's good stuff
all right
fiery shark says my grandfather worked
at a slaughterhouse in the 90s he killed
500 pigs a day and let's just say this
the the stun stick used to knock uh used
to knock unconscious was never used
because too slow he would all he would
have been fired it's sad that is really
sad I'm gonna go curl up in a ball and
have a good cry after this yeah this is
a tough episode wow jeez
all right
Ian Crossland on Twitter on uh Super
Chat says Tim can you talk can you ask
Ian to talk about graphene more it's a
username
yesterday uh we called him graphy you
said that uh he replaced something with
graphene what was that oh oh we have
footage of that we were improvising we
brought something about grab I think we
were like doing a fake Tim cast episode
and oh man and Sheamus was pretending to
be Ian and that said something about
about graphene dude we're talking about
fluoride and he's like replace the
camera we need to replace the floor I
would graph yeah or something graphing
tattoos yeah yeah I'll definitely talk
about graphene more thanks for the Super
Chat thanks Ian yeah it had nothing to
do with that
oh my gosh no all right the Raptor's
Talent says Mr Freedom Tunes Ian was
simply saying that the article had
loaded language in it Ian please be more
careful about what you call propaganda
it's difficult enough to listen to this
episode we don't need an argument about
loaded language yeah I'll use I thought
the language was fine I'll use it to
stream um examples sometimes to make my
point and it can evoke an emotional
response
yeah you know I mean I was fine with the
language
whoa PRC E5 says years ago markless
Marcus Latrell the Navy SEAL that Lone
Survivor is about chased people who
killed his dog 100 miles an hour check
out the 9-1-1 call crazy wow good for
him John Wick man yeah John Wick that's
why it's a good movie you know why
because I I understood totally identify
with that totally understood 100 little
dog and he's just like I know I have to
kill him thinking about Buckle man like
yeah the property but they're dudes
they're like people they have
personalities I would say they're people
but they do have personality in some
countries actually say that elephants
are people they get them and dolphins
because they're so smart they give them
personnel personal bucko hangs out he's
a cat and so like we'll like we were all
chilling in the living room with like
the movie on and he comes in and jumps
up on a chair and he's like sitting in a
chair and everybody and you know he's
doing his thing hey Tim if he was bigger
than me he'd definitely remember
yesterday when I said I was gonna
control when you said well that's true
if the cat is bigger than you that cat I
mean look at tigers you know sometimes
they go missing
um bro Tim I told you yesterday that I
was gonna I was gonna wear a suit then
it was going to be my podcast because I
was the one wearing a suit it looks
great too this is a coup that's the
whole reason I bought this cast iron
exactly this Sheamus cast IRL I want
everyone at home to know I'm gonna tell
everyone to start calling you James this
is starting James
IRL bro why am I not reading the super
chats I uh this is my podcast now I want
to thank uh I want to thank Tim for
coming by
so can we call you shim for short
shimcast IRL here shimmy sham Sheamus
Sheamus is Gaelic for James that's right
and then what's James like British uh
James is a British version of Jacob
grabs at the heel yes so planting so if
if no man asked Omen that means I
replace you bro if James is Jim then
Sheamus is shim that's right shim sham
coggles but they call me on the South
Side you know what they really call me
on the South Side afraid I don't go
there often nice
all right let's see
little Tails Farm says Tim when our
black I am Simoni chickens we just got
start laying eggs I'll send you some
they are highly sought after and
beautiful PS thanks for the idea chicken
City we're filming building hours now
good for you we are in construction for
the new chicken City so
that's right we needed a better way to
get the cameras and and so it was going
to take really long cables and we were
like we need to move this to better have
like to have the layout better and uh so
now there's also a dog on the property
too which is gonna it's basically all
the all the critters are gone and we are
we are also incubating some of the
babies if you want to send eggs what
about some fertilized ones that we can
put in the incubator and then make more
chickens
yeah we're growing them that's right got
the incubator going and yeah Tim show me
he has a flashlight special like egg
flashlight you put the egg on the
flashlight and you can see like the
blood vessels inside yeah you can see
the chicken actually doing chicken stuff
oh wow yeah inside the egg it's so cool
yep
all right let's see we got
Erica Britt says Peta kills animals on a
regular basis claiming that they are
saving them look it up are they doing it
kills animals.com yeah wow are they
doing anything good for animal rights no
like what is the problem what happened
they used to be right no I think that
it's always been a cash grab see when
they take these animals anytime that an
animal is seized Under The Endangered
Species Act the government will pay for
their care they basically pay child
support and Welfare and so all of this
it's all about money I don't believe
that they are actually genuinely doing
anything other than trying to get
teenage girls to do naked stunts for
their yeah that's not disgusting I hate
Peta yeah no I noticed that too they've
also you know they've also done like a
lot of anti-catholic stuff too I know
they try to get real edgy by like having
naked women in their ads and bashing the
church it's like whoa you're so
contrarian uh they are they're they're
horrible yeah I can't think of anything
the good that they've done I mean maybe
letting people see what happens to like
baby chicks
um you know they've released some
footage of that but I don't even think
that they're the ones that got it I
think they just steal it from other
people like uh you know there was uh
Phil up in Canada who blew the whistle
on Marineland and he was a a walrus
trainer and he did all these amazing
things and then when Marineland came
after him and started you know the
lawsuits Peter was nowhere to be found
they were fundraising off his name and
then they did not help at all with his
legal fees or anything like that and
they're still fundraising using
marineland's name and
um they're just terrible I hate them I I
don't like to say that you really feel
yeah I feel like Cassandra I mean I
honestly I their vice president blocked
me on Twitter today I've been on a
crusade and it's not ending ever you
guys know how I am when people like hurt
my friends these guys went after my
friends and now it's War we got we got a
super chat for you bro skadoodle says
Cassandra have you ever watched the Penn
and teller's BS episode on Pita yeah I
highly recommend it um I think it was on
YouTube if people want to go watch it
highly recommend it's great the whole BS
can't say it obviously bullish amazing
show Yeah by Penn and Teller however
they did mention that the show is very
loaded yeah so the episode on Peta was
good you can Factor this stuff but they
it's a loaded show so you gotta you
gotta make sure you keep that watching
the things that they say are true though
no for sure I I mean these are all facts
that you can go if you go to
peterkillsanimals.com they have all the
documents from the Virginia inspectors
they have they have you know a plethora
of information that you can go dig
through yourself it's not like opinion
pieces like they have the documents they
have the photos I highly recommend going
and looking at it I really think you'd
be great if you did a podcast I know you
said you don't like being on camera I
don't want to pressure you I'm just
telling you I think you do great no I
ramble I've been rambling I get so
nervous because she is gonna contribute
to our new Mystery Spot that's right oh
cool
so we're gonna have a lot a lot of stuff
it's gonna be fun we're actually
planning on hiring an additional writer
so we've got Shane Cashman he does at
once a week these these these long-form
stories they're really good stuff it's
really good stuff exploring these ideas
and like checking out these weird spooky
Mysteries and then we're going to add
articles to the show which are like less
well short form news so like when
there's UFO sighting or government
report or like there was a Bigfoot
sighting recently do you guys see this
no no is it in West Virginia I don't I
don't know but I think of Bigfoot
Hunters all right I forget to wear my
shirt one day and go outside and all of
a sudden it's Bigfoot side it's
extremely I don't believe it's really a
photo of Bigfoot but apparently so it's
like we're gonna have someone writing
about the the the the Unexplained and
you know these fun stories we're very
skeptical it's a very academic approach
to things but it's fun to be like I
wonder what what is that because are you
skeptical
Bigfoot I do not believe exists I bet
there used to be giant hominids like uh
what was it um Denise Evans Dennis yeah
but but that they're extinct there's a
Bigfoot um group that actually meets in
our neighborhood of course yes of course
there is and there's you know there's
people who swear that there's a juvenile
Bigfoot that live around our we've been
talking about the underground caves on
earth like that we don't really know
much about and there could be lots of
Life what if they have the ability to
phase through solid matter and that's
why we don't see them because as soon as
they notice they're there they just
sling down underground by phasing
Through Math it's more real more
realistic yes my community is so
wholesome that this woman got lost while
she was walking her dog and she was fine
she just took a wrong turn and it was
dark out nobody could find her but
people had posted in our neighborhood
group being like hey This Woman's
missing we need to go find her and
everybody went looking for and nobody
would even entertain the possibility
that she had been hurt by a human or
kidnapped or something everybody was
just convinced that if she had been
taken it was by a big friend definitely
and I was like I love my neighborhood
but why would anyone in your
neighborhood hurt somebody right we have
another crime though right there's like
there's no way she got hurt it had to
have been Bigfoot of course and
everybody was earnestly like you know if
it was it would have had to have been a
creature that was very tall and had
human arms like a human but not a human
because duh and it was just like so cute
I will I will say though people got
people got at the range got really mad
because during the search they were
walking sweeping through the forest yeah
and people were actively [ __ ] as a
range on the mountain and they were like
what are you doing can't you hear what's
going on you can't walk this way it's
it's so dangerous but you know they
weren't really paying attention yeah all
right Christopher Coulter says morally
indefensible acts remain indefensible
despite the scientific value and there
is a perverse incentive structure
inherent to the argument even if the
scientists have no direct involvement in
the abortion of the child Amen brother
that's a really really good point she's
perverse science man what a debate well
this is why we need philosophy and
there's so many scientists who scoff at
this too I've I've heard people who are
very popular I won't name names but who
consider themselves activists for
Science and they'll say well science
gets you real results and philosophy is
stupid it's like all right what year is
it you know it's 2021 we still don't
have a perfectly completed science of
diet frankly people still argue for what
we should be eating but we've been able
to create bombs using the scientific
method that have killed 200 000 people
with one drop right in Hiroshima
nagasaka I should say two drops my point
is science is an incredibly powerful
tool but it needs to be constrained by
ethics
here's a good one Paul phone cam says as
an episode of Stargate sg1 where there's
people living in a dome on a polluted
Planet the Dome was shrinking the
computer AI solution was to send people
outside the Dome to die and erase the
memory of that person from citizen
memory I just saw this it was just on
recently and it's a really good episode
basically what happens is for those
aren't familiar with Stargate there is a
portal it's called the Stargate and
they're exploring a network of addresses
they have to all these different planets
they go to one and they send uh this
machine like the Drone and then they see
the whole planet it's like the
atmosphere is totally toxic you'll die
and then they drive forward and it
enters this weird force field where
everything's normal looking trees and
buildings and they're like whoa so they
put on suits they go and they find the
city of about 1700 people and they're
like yeah we're the last survivors on
this planet how did you get here and
there's a council with four people on it
and they are trying to discuss you know
about you know saving lives or something
we got to get you out of here and then
the next day the council only has three
people and they're like what happened to
the lady and they're like what lady like
the fourth person they're like there was
no fourth person there's never been a
fourth person they wore this thing
called the link which connected their
brains to the central Ai and what they
thought they thought it was giving them
access to the summation of their
knowledge and then eventually they end
up discovering that the force field is
shrinking because the power it's running
out and the the city used to have a
hundred thousand people in it and it had
been been diminished and what there was
one guy and he they go to his house and
he's got a wife
and the wife is helping one of the one
of the characters decipher like old old
texts and then all of a sudden one day
the woman gets up and then walks
straight outside the force field and
just dies and you don't see what happens
just walks out and then when they go to
the husband they're like what happened
to your wife and he goes
I don't have a wife I've never been
married
and so the AI was like to prevent chaos
and rioting and panic just erase using
the link into people's minds to erase
their memory of the people one by one
they're just disappearing
they wouldn't be able to find a solution
because they didn't know there was a
problem and that's a really I think a
really good point about AI too is that
the AI is like this is going to allow
them to survive as long as possible but
with human Ingenuity perhaps if they
knew there was a problem they could have
fixed their energy crisis but the
machine didn't care and he was just
serving its purpose I mean unfortunately
this is what happens with a lot of
totalitarian leaders they say things
like well I will improve the human
condition for everyone if I just kill
this handful of people and then it ends
up spiraling out of control and it's
more than a handful of people but you
don't need some dystopian artificial
intelligence to get you there we've seen
it before yeah social media censorship
if you don't know there's a problem how
are you going to fix it um yeah you
censor the problem away then it's going
to affect well but I mean even prior I'm
talking even prior to social media
people are people in control are very
good at masquerading their homicidal
lust for a concern for Humanity oh it
will actually help people by doing this
job B says Cassandra will you will you
please do a video on the Highgate
Cemetery slash vampire I'm fascinated by
it
I'm not actually sure I know that I've
heard the name
but I am blinking let's look it up for
sure yeah yeah
Jennifer Presley says Tim so you weren't
one of us kids that had walkie-talkies
in the late 80s uh in the late 80s I was
three I had walkie-talkies three three
years old Ian why you gotta Flex like
that bro what's up from the 70s yeah
that's crazy
to hear Ian is 40. I don't believe it
holla back at you yeah I used to have a
Ricky data Roper backpack Goonies for
life we had walkie talkies in the 90s
walkie talkies as a kid and like that
90s early 2000s
I had a rotary phone when I was going
yeah me too remember how cool you
thought a walkie-talkie was and now you
can FaceTime people and it's like eh
right it's there's no novelty anymore
anywhere in the world you can
walkie-talkie anyone dude with cheat
codes that's so true yeah I tried to get
my daughter walkie-talkies because I was
like oh you can like talk to your friend
she's just down the street she's like
I'll just Skype her she's like I can
literally just you know what I can see
her face and have a not be fuzzy it's
like oh yeah I think it's funny that
when you watch movies like um uh
Demolition Man they really thought back
in the 80s and early 90s that the future
would be pay phones with like cameras so
you could see people or like they would
go to their wall and press the button
and they would see it's like a video
phone was the idea and then we did make
it but nobody predicted that we'd have
computers in our Park you know it's
ironic it would actually probably be
better for Humanity if our interface
technology for looking at someone else's
face when they're far away from us was a
kind of Payphone structure because we
wouldn't have this thing in our pocket
all the time distracting us from
everything what what was it what there's
this show maybe it's Black Mirror where
like probably people got banned from
society so when you saw them you just
saw like a silhouette yeah yeah
disturbing yeah they're muted you could
block people in real life block mirror
yeah but that's kind of dumb because
what if they're nuts and they're gonna
attack you right you know right you need
to like you simply hit undo yeah but you
don't know if like you can't see them
you just hit edit undo after they stab
you you're good that's right you're like
something it's all a simulation anyway
stabbed oh man
I'm not gonna lie to you there have been
times when I've been drawing on paper
and I make a mistake and for half a
second I think to click undo
I don't know if you could develop
precognition and see five seconds into
the Future Would you no really yeah
no what about you Cassandra I don't
think so wait what was that if you could
develop precognition and have the
ability to see five seconds into the
Future Would you yes I would too because
you'd be able to predict have you ever
seen the movie Next
no no this is really so it's it's
Nicholas oh I have seen this I think
it's a great movie I think it's really
it's fun
um he can he can see a certain amount of
time into the future so he's he's able
to make these moves like perfectly but
there's one scene it's brilliant where
he's looking for someone in a room in in
an industrial setting and then you see
him walk forward and then all of a
sudden four versions of him walk out in
each different direction because what
he's doing is he he's walking forward
and then using his precognition looking
at what happens if he walks forward and
turns left walks forward turns right
walks forward goes forward again turns
left and so he's seeing everything all
at once and then he goes they're there
in the back of the left room and then he
just instantly knows because he can see
it's not just about seeing the future
it's about seeing the future of all the
different possibilities of the actions
you might take
but what you've never talked about
earlier you get cheat codes things are
boring yeah yeah like the world we have
the cheat codes now we just still need
to beat the game but it's boring because
we have our cheat codes but it's like no
you still got to beat it you still got
to play it through with the cheat codes
I mean maybe you know I'd be down to be
fun
you know you'd go skateboarding you'd
never get hurt ever again
if there's no risk yes you don't think
that adds to the thrill at all it a
little bit but it would be great because
you'd be like I want to try the craziest
trick and then you see the future of you
falling and breaking your leg a bit I
won't try that one you still got to get
the skills to be able to do the trick
you can't just pretend you can't just
jump on a rail if you've never skated
before you gotta get good but okay so
here's the thing what if there are
things which are inherently risky and if
you do them enough to get good you have
to get hurt at some point but you never
allow yourself to get hurt because of
the precognition so you've got weak
mental Force you never get good oh
interesting the fear of the risk
prevents you from taking but what if
what if you don't know what if you don't
so like what if like let's say it is
just it's it's a fact that in order to
get good at skateboarding you have to
hurt yourself actually a number of times
yeah it happens but you have this
precognition and you avoid anything
that's going to hurt you because you
think there's a way of getting good
without getting it's very it's very very
simple then you have a weak mind I go
skating I go skating every day and I
know I'm gonna fall and I fell several
times today granted I've been
rollerblading more than skateboarding
recently sure but you you get out there
and you escape but before you fall you
don't know that you're any more likely
to fall than you were at any other time
when you get on your skateboard right it
just happens unexpectedly I think if you
expect it it makes you less likely to do
it no you expect a full that's how you
want you don't know for sure you're
gonna fall like if you could see five
seconds into the future and you knew you
were gonna fall off your skateboard this
time
you might be less likely to do it well
it depends because a a bail isn't a slam
sometimes you slam and slamming messes
you up and takes you out bailing is
normal bailing is the you can get hurt a
little bit bailing is when you choose to
bail off of the trick and slamming is
when you unexpectedly get hurt I think
that's interesting so getting I gotta be
honest getting hurt less you'd become
way better you'd make a good point
though Sheamus because sometimes
mistakes are what make us better yeah
good point yeah and and so like saying
the wrong thing to someone that upsets
them in the short term might hurt but
make you both stronger people afterwards
yeah
Luke Keller says Tim the guy who said
that the term factory farms is a fake
made up word used by MSM to destroy
Farmers as correct the vast majority of
farms are family owned and operated 99
of beef cattle are owned by Family Farms
it's why we are most under assault it
sounds like a psyop what is this is this
insane world I'm not I didn't say that
they were that factory farms were the
overall majority right I didn't say that
most Farms are factory farms I said
there are farms that are mistreating
animals
it happens I don't know
but uh all the Farms out here they're so
beautiful so it's so much fun when you
go like I went to one farm and they had
this big pen and they had like a hundred
chickens and it was hilarious just
watching them all there was there was a
young rooster it was Tiny and he was
like smack talking and like strutting
around and I'm like look at this
pathetic little thing it's hilarious and
then you walk over and the goats are
jumping off stuff and you know it's
hilarious dude you have a rooster that
talks some smack on the compound he does
yes we didn't know he had arrested he's
just constantly screaming he does his
time he goes he doesn't have the all the
spikes on his feet it's really
interesting so the farmer thought it was
a a hen a baby a female and so we
weren't expecting to get a rooster and
then all of a sudden started becoming a
rooster and going and we were like what
was that Tim I think we should just eat
it but there's no foot spikes you know
like the roosters that's fine with me no
I guess you don't eat rooster no because
it's like they're tough yeah
there has to be something all right I'm
just saying your Rooster's broken he
screams all day long it's not just in
the morning when the sun comes up
every couple minutes
are roosters just they just scream all
the time I'm such a city slicker I
didn't know this she just sits there and
screams all day but not all the time
it's so weird sometimes it's just right
this is just been warning time warning
Predators he's just talking smack well
he warned me I'm scared of him I'm
really I'm really glad too because uh
roosters will sacrifice themselves to
protect the the ladies and it's really
funny when we let them out into the
garden to do their daily you know
chicken business he won't eat he'll just
like stand there watching as all the
ladies are eating and enjoying
themselves I like him now you know
imagine that imagine that imagine a
world where the women are safe and
comfortable and they're all you know
happily going around eating all our
little zucchinis because there is a big
strong rooster who's like I will forego
eating for now to make sure you can all
eat safely I love it would that impose
any sort of role on the women because
then that's not a chicken
you can get right up in his face and
he'll still scream at you but it's real
weird like his eyes are still he'll be
looking at you and he's like I love it
eye contact you know yeah and then he
got pecked and he's like I wish I did
there was a cage between us I love him
but he's moving we're moving the
roosters outside of my room oh God so I
may want to murder that thing at some
point I don't know you will yeah no
you're certainly going to one emergency
maybe you should stop waking up at 7 pm
I do keep weird hours that's also true
yeah we've had like guests who are
really excited like I really want to
meet Ian I'm so excited he's sleeping
too bad they're like but I gotta leave
at like six
I'll have to meet him next time ladies
and gentlemen it's been a fabulous
Friday night thanks for hanging out
thanks for watching a whole lot of fun
um you can follow the show at Tim cast
IRL basically everywhere and you can
follow me personally at timcast go to
timcast.com become a member help support
our Fierce and independent journalism
from people like Cassandra amen thank
you do you want to shout anything out
um it is not enough to not support Peta
we must be active
[Laughter]
there you go you rock thanks for coming
everyone you can cross them peace and
love
I love what you just said I'm absolutely
going to steal let's just pretend it was
original when I say it um
he's been shimcast IRL I want everybody
to know it's no it's that's me it's not
enough to to oppose abortion we have to
be actively that's right abortion and
thank you for watching I know we got
into some dark topics but it was well
worth it God bless all of you please
pray the rosary uh for an end to
abortion and do everything that you can
talk to people about this if you know
someone considering an abortion be brave
tell them you know uh that this is an
unborn child give them the information
that they need in order to choose life I
think offer them support yes you know
like become say yes I will help you if
you have this job please you should
because that is a child and what you're
going to do is end their life yeah yeah
my mother used to work in a a like an
anti-abortion support Clinic where these
people would go if they were thinking
about having an abortion my mom was like
please don't have an abortion we have
these clothes we have diapers we have
everything you need and I thought that
was wonderful because that was one of
the one of the greatest things she did
I'm on on the side of Sheamus here I
don't think that anybody should have an
abortion ever so if you know somebody
who's considering having abortion please
direct them to uh uh what's it called
Sheamus what's called a crisis pregnancy
it's important to know that many many
women who have had abortions say that
it's because they didn't feel they had
any other option they had no other
support you have to be that support for
them that's right send them to a crisis
pregnancy they will help them I will I
will add well I I just I can't stand the
meme from the left where they say like
conservatives don't but you know are
pro-life until the baby's born and I'm
like d I don't think they follow any
conservatives because like I follow
bunch of conservatives and they're
always posting about orphanages and like
taking care of kids and adopting and
providing support and donating and I'm
like I don't think that's true I think
you just want to believe it's true
because it kind of absolves you of some
responsibility to blame someone else
yeah exactly 100 it's it's projection
it's projection right because they tend
not to care all that much for the groups
that they advocate for I mean they
imagine if the same standard reply to
them they'll say things like oh you're
pro-life how can you be pro-life if you
haven't adopted any children all right
well like how many refugees have you
paid the house yourself none of them do
I know I actually know many pro-life
people who have adopted children I don't
really know left-wing people who have
put money on the table to help them
marginalize groups that they claim to
advocate for I know so many uh
conservative people who are very
pro-life and have adopted children like
yeah there's Gina Louden there's there's
all kinds of people who who are doing
that
um
so yeah you gotta get out of that
propaganda bubble man because you're
you're allowed to have whatever politics
you want so long as you can recognize
like objective reality then we all kind
of disagree on a lot of things but at
least we can have real conversations
about things that we
saw this show nightmares but I'll I'll
leave it there did you shout out your
Twitter I didn't you guys are more than
welcome to follow me at sour patch litz
lyds on on Twitter I routinely tweet
extremely pro-life things that is my
health dying so that's why like
tonight's tonight's show is definitely
why that happens so yeah follow me there
yeah myself as well at Sheamus
underscore and I tweet a lot of pro-life
stuff um Freedom Tunes is my YouTube
channel we did another yeah and I did
another faucy cartoon Tim voice fouchy
it was beautiful I thought the cartoon
came out very well so check that out and
thank you for tuning in to shimcast IRL
that's right thank you guys for being my
guest Tim I always appreciate when you
come on thanks Lydia YouTube
Anytime of course go to timcast.com
become a member and we'll see you all I
don't think we're gonna have the Vlog up
tomorrow
um because we're shuffling around we
hired more people because we're trying
to make the Vlog daily but maybe Sunday
so youtube.com cast castle if you've
been missing these episodes you are
really missing out because Kant has been
doing animations oh my gosh there was
just one amazing one where Ian's like
I'm on the roof and I decided to let
down my magnetic force field into this
wolf hominid it was he wants to eat me
and then Ian goes I was high I was
Stones
check out the Vlogs man we'll see you
all next time bye guys